Freedom Convoy truckers are warning
nefarious elements may try to plant
weapons in a false flag stolen weapons
nonetheless after 11 people were
arrested with the weapons cash
they're trying everything they can to
stop this group of protesters
doesn't seem to be working Trudeau's
invoking these emergency powers for the
first time he's being condemned widely
for it and there's a really funny meme
from political Compass memes because I
retweeted vosh who criticized Trudeau
and they're like What's Happening you
know and it shows like a stone toss
comic and it's like me and vosh are like
shaking hands and then people are
commenting commenting that Tim's a
Centrist so this is not as shocking as
people like I think it is but anyway
it's kind of scary how uh how far it's
gone in Canada but I think it should uh
should bring about optimism because it
shows you that these protests work
you've also uh We've also got the Ottawa
Police Chief I believe this is police
chief yeah yeah he's resigned yeah yeah
slowly and another report saying that
those donations that were being sent to
the truckers yeah actually most of them
came from Canada it was not America like
Trudeau was trying to argue so we'll get
into all of that stuff plus we have a
creepy CGI video
the family of the cinematographer killed
by Alec Baldwin has filed a lawsuit
they've released a CGI video showing
exactly how it went down or at least the
description of how it went down and as
much as I don't like acting like CGI
video as evidence I think it will help
people understand why
well how it went down it was indoors it
was in a type you know this location it
you'll see what the building kind of
looked like it's an artist rendering of
it I'm going to maintain my position I
think uh I think Alec Baldwin killed
that woman I don't I think it may have
been accidental but I think it may have
been just a fit of rage something ain't
right there and so with this new lawsuit
new information is coming out we're
going to talk about all that plus we
have Remington settling a massive
lawsuit over 70 million dollars and this
one just makes absolutely no sense to me
but joining us to talk about all of this
is Mr Drew Hernandez thank you guys for
having me it's always fun it's always
fun to be here with the gang can you
guys hear me
yeah introduce yourself good sir
well for those of you that don't know me
and I may my name is Drew Hernandez I've
done a lot of on the ground reporting
you may have seen my stuff from the 2020
riots and stuff like that and we have
some announcements to make tonight as
well with a brand new show as well so
it's gonna be fun right on we all got
Chris Carr hanging out yes sir thanks
for having me back good to be here and
who are you sir I am the executive
editor of The Newsroom for timcast.com
got the Rockstar journalist turning out
great work every single day yeah great
website yeah good site yeah yeah they're
really lucky they have all those members
over at timcast.com allowing allowing
the hiring of such great reporters we
love you all and we got Ian what's up
everybody Ian Crossland good to see you
and I'm also here pushing buttons in the
corner trying to get the sound just
right tweaking it we check it every
night but sometimes it's still a little
high but we're gonna have a great show
tonight stoked to have drew back again
yeah I I noticed though Ian you never
introduce yourself leave it to the
imagination oh my gosh a guy with a
bunch of weird rocks in front of him
this talks about DMT and graphene is it
human
human all right everybody before we get
started we have an awesome sponsor we
have BioTrust head over to each right
and feelwell.com and you can get 51 off
of your keto Elevate C8 MCT oil powder
this stuff's awesome you mix it in your
drinks you mix it in your your coffee
that's what I like to do and it provides
you with all that excellent ketogenic
energy using uh granting you the medium
chain triglycerides if you head over to
eat rightandfillwell.com not only will
you get 51 off you'll get a 60-day
money-back guarantee
here to elevate provides your body only
C8 the most ketogenic MCT that means it
provides support for energy levels
healthy appetite Management Mental
Clarity and focus athletic performance
you'll get five grams of the highly
sought after mctc8 per scoop keto
Elevate personally my favorite I love
mixing into my my coffee as I explained
you'll get free shipping on every order
and for every order today BioTrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year with your order you will get
free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their e-report the
top 14 ketogenic foods with your order
so again go to eat write and
feelwell.com Shout out thank you so much
for sponsoring the show BioTrust and
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member because we're going to have a
special members only segment coming up
for all of you guys after the show these
are for uh our members to help you know
give you something in exchange I suppose
those are Monday through Thursday 11 pm
but as a member you will help keep all
of our staffers employed and that's the
most important thing I suppose we run
the operation primarily off of your
memberships not to mention we know we do
have sponsors for sure but you know we
run off membership so don't forget to
sign up and also smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's check out that
first big story from the Daily Mail
Freedom Convoy leaders claim nefarious
elements are planning to plant two
thousand stolen guns on protesters in
Ottawa to discredit their movement after
mounties arrested 11 with cachet of
firearms in Alberta Convoy security
Chief Danny bulford made the allegation
in a video address late Monday night
claimed nefarious elements plan to plant
firearms on demonstrators to discredit
them suggested the plot could be linked
to a truck filled with guns stolen in
Ontario early Sunday morning police say
that the truck was stolen as a crime of
opportunity by Crooks who first tried
several other trucks but bulford thinks
it could be a dark plot to crack down
after Trudeau's emergency Declaration on
Monday mounties seized 15 guns and
arrested 11 at a border blockade in Kutz
Alberta Convoy leaders have declined to
address the arrests cutting off a press
conference when asked about them now I
don't know about all that uh false flag
stuff conspiracy stuff but I I will say
they're trying everything in their power
to shut this down so what what do you
guys think in terms of plausibility for
something like this well I think from
the very get-go
um what's been happening in Canada is
just completely slanderous I mean
they've been calling them domestic
terrorists they've been calling them a
threat they've been calling them
insurrectionists it's like the same
buzzwords you see across the entire
board they do the same thing with j6 but
this is is interesting because
they're legitimately peaceful people in
this protest but they still use these
words in these slander against them so
you you have to ask yourself like you're
seeing their federal government try so
hard to slander who these people really
are I mean this this is a protest with
bounce houses and Inflatables and
there's children and people are just
demanding freedom and it's like not
violent but when you read something like
that it's really not that too far off to
be like huh
maybe something like that could be going
on because they're trying to slander
these people from the very get-go you
know well that's the problem is that the
slander is not sticking right so at this
point they have to make these people
look violent and I think they would
probably resort to any means in order to
do that yeah yeah I'm not one for these
kinds of conspiracies you know show me
show me the hard evidence speculation
that the challenge I suppose though is
they've tried everything you know
they've tried claiming this violence
they've tried uh
flag they haven't done the n-word yet
let's see if they can say one of the
characters
none of it is working yeah they're
trying everything and anything to
discredit people that just want freedom
that's what people people need to like
really these are people demanding
Freedom they want bodily autonomy right
like they're really not calling for
anything else other than we don't want
to be forced to take a jab right we want
freedom that's what we want and it's
crazy when you see them slander them as
like you know they're xenophobic when
you have like minorities or you have
immigrants that are truckers in Canada
there's a viral video of these like
Indian guys and they're on chairs or
whatever they're bouncing and playing
music and everyone's dancing to it and
it's like Punjabi music yeah and those
those are the xenophobes those are the
racists but it's like it's these same
buzzwords over and over again but I just
I think people really need to ask
themselves like what you got to think
about it invertedly right if you're a
totalitarian psychopath those people are
terrorists in your eyes those people are
a problem those people do pose a threat
to you because if you are a totalitarian
psychopath anyone that's demanding
freedom in any way shape or form by
definition that's what they are in your
eyes and I think a lot of Canadians that
are just kind of in the hive mind right
now and shout out to Canada I love the
Canadians man but there's there's a lot
of people out there that just eat up
just like here in the United States that
eat up these lies and they just believe
them and they gravitate towards them
it's like although the government said
so so it must be true but
these in a sense what I'm trying to say
is they do they they are a threat to the
regime they they are terrorists to the
regime because they are they pose a
threat to what they want to control if
you're the the uh High Life royalty atop
your Ivory Tower and the peasants have
made their way in Heavens yeah they're
absolutely disruptive to your way of
life it's the Lord of our quad mentality
yeah yeah yes exactly and I think people
need to just just have you ever stopped
to consider the perspective of Trudeau
you know he's sitting there mining his
own business with his team crumpets and
expensive champagnes when all of a
sudden these dirty pores are trying to
tell him what to do I mean yeah these
people absolutely are terrorists going
after him oh heavens oh yeah he's he's
given us explicit insight into how he
views who he is versus who the
deplorables are because that video
that's recirculated lately of him
talking about how much he admires China
and the Chinese government for being
able to I think he said be able to turn
their economy around on a dime whatever
that means and at the same time in that
video he also in Soul
they want to end the vaccine mandates
yeah but they want more I just watched a
video with a trucker on national news uh
somewhere I should find on Twitter it
was like British news or something and
music so what what do you want and the
guy's like we want you know we want we
want he's like you want to end the Mac
the Mandate the vaccine made it he's
like yeah we want to end that what else
do you want we want freedom and I'm like
what is that I think he wants like an
American Constitution but no it's vague
and so they don't know if they tell you
Ian we want to end the mandates and
you're expecting more than that it's
like and what else once they do that
will you go wrong you're like no and
then he was like saying there's more but
they want freedom and like they want
just want freedom like what does that
even mean and who are they talking to I
don't know man
the whole thing is about the vax
mandates all right and that's why they
give you one response but of course
there's other things that they want to
be respected they want to be heard
they're tired of the abuse I will say in
response to this guy coming out and
saying there's a potential false flag
smart
because they're going to smear us crazy
they're going to say oh he's a
conspiracy theorist well better than
letting them come with a big truckload
of guns
yeah the other part of what I was going
to say is I'm glad that this this story
is shouting out that there are leaders
involved because that was problem with
act by Wall Street deserves no
leadership and so there was no unified
message and it dissipated I hope that
these leaders can put one together
yeah I think they do have very strong
leaders and I know that one of the
things that I was seeing from the Press
was they were saying that the word
Freedom has become supposedly a
right-wing talking point and I was like
there you go that's it that's how that's
that's how everything's shaking out
right now and that's how you know which
side of History you want to be on do you
want to be on the side of history that
says that freedom is a right-wing
talking point or do you actually care
about freedom and want people to make
their own choices ninety percent of
truckers have gotten vaccinated and it's
not enough for them they're still not
allowing that last 10 percent to live
freely and to work Freeland across the
border freely that's all they want they
just don't want the last 10 percent who
feel like they shouldn't have to take it
to have to take it that's basically what
they want that's their version of
freedom I was laughing this past weekend
because the counter protester started
coming out you know they're running
around with their with their commie
flags and all that right and you see
some of these protests I post this on
Twitter the other last weekend some of
them are like throwing themselves in
front of trucks like into oncoming
traffic and it's like so your your
counter protesting people shut down
streets by shutting down streets and
throwing yourself in front of oncoming
traffic because you know that just makes
total sense it really does in a very
counterintuitive a very human ancient
way they are advocating for enslavement
they really are and that's and that's
not the first time this has happened
like that does happen some sometimes in
certain cultures people advocate for
enslavement and they're literally doing
that and it's terrifying there were a
lot of people that were defending Ron
DeSantis and Florida when they're
passing this bill the anti-writing law
that makes it a felony to block the
roads in certain circumstances and I
said nah man you can't that's why I'm
not in favor of that and we've had
people come here and argue and say no
there should be harsh penalties for
these people and and we always say this
you pass a law it will be used against
you now of course this is up in Canada I
know not Florida on the same thing but
uh if we want to have an American
trucker protest all of a sudden these
anti-right laws come into play they're
the left will be laughing and being oh
you got what you got what you asked for
here we go baby we're gonna start a
rescue resting all these guys on felony
charges so I think you've got to give
room to non-violence Civil Disobedience
that being said as for what's going on
in Canada Trudeau's lost the plot War
Powers or emergency powers or whatever
he's doing over what bouncy house
overflatable but think about it it's
over jacuzzis it's over people not
wanting to to serve not wanting to to
participate and so they're treating
these people who are just saying no to
the system as if they're violent
extremists
it is so interesting to me because the
smacks of what America is trying to do
by painting all right-wing people as a
form of terrorists because one of the
things that the emergency powers in
Canada are supposed to do they're
supposed to protect Canadians from like
actual threats to their physical
well-being and I think it was Ben
Shapiro I was listening to earlier today
made the point about how there were
riots in Canada like last year not to
the extent there were in the US but the
black lives matter stuff was going on in
Canada as well never shut that down they
never said we need emergency powers for
that that was actually a threat to
Canadian businesses and to Canadian
lives and well-beings and they just
didn't care this is different this is
political this is deeply troubling to me
a serious problem with this not good
yeah it sure does uh
he seems sad
he seems to worry about his videos and
it's just like yeah he's talking with
Biden he has no idea how to handle this
and what he's doing now isn't working
yeah and that's they're they're beyond
desperate but what do they do hmm what
do you what do you do you know he's like
I'm not going to call in the military I
won't do it but eventually
you know
if he moves in and uses Force it'll only
make it worse so it's time you know he
and the rest of them realize they lost
it's over is this Crackdown going to
work I mean after what going on three
weeks of this or two and a half or
whatever it is I'm really curious to
know if this Crackdown will work I don't
know if it will or Define work
will it be a CCP style suppression of
people that are literally advocating for
Freedom like tianmen Square exactly
that's exactly what I'm thinking of will
they will they uh move into that realm
of suppression and will it work because
it's worked over there it works but it
works to like get the trucks off the
road but whether or not it works to
preserve Canadian you know freedom I I
don't think I don't think that I don't
think you can blast your own citizens
and expect to stay in power in this day
and age well there's different Canada
there's different Arts of warfare right
there's obviously like military Powers
there's physical war and then there's
monetary like there's an economic War
right there's there's cyber warfare
there's all types of different ways you
can go about take taking your enemy out
and I think they're clearly right now
using psychological warfare and they're
shutting down bank accounts they're
trying to use economic Warfare by
Drowning these people out they already
took to the streets and tried to take
their gas but I think they're trying
these different things and and in my
opinion I think they're they're they're
pretty serious things I mean when you're
trying to like shut down someone's bank
account because they're asking for
Freedom that's a huge problem to me
that's just a serious in my opinion yeah
I could see like what is these 24 year
olds gonna get their bank account shut
down for the rest of their lives is that
the plan Justin no dude without court
orders
maybe this is just lining everybody up
for when the social credit score uh
comes in yeah this is just prepping it
all or you know uh I was saying this
story reminds me of Watchmen you know
maybe in order for them to uh for for
the powerful Elites to enact their one
world currencies or whatever you know
International free trade agreements they
want to get through they need people to
unify around the villain they be they
embody all the things they don't want
people to do be jerks about it and then
everyone pulls back and doesn't does the
opposite so Bitcoin for instance how do
you get Mass adoption of a different
currency destroy the other one be a
villain make everyone think it's the
safe haven quick everybody run bitcoin's
the only way to save you they're
phrasing our bank accounts then all of a
sudden everyone's using a global digital
store of value that's trackable so they
used to hunt Buffalo man they just chase
them off a cliff scare them to run
towards wherever they thought was safe
and it happened to be a cliff and then
they'll climb down and just pick them up
yep that's how I don't know like uh
Hawks and like Falcons or whatever they
do for goats oh maybe I don't know yeah
like the mountain goats will climb up
and be looking salt or something and
then the big bird just swoops it and
hits it and then just flips off the
cliffs oh yeah I've seen them do that
that's wild yeah that's one way to do it
that's one way to do it man you know
this is this is I think I saw a Trudeau
uh quote earlier today I think he was
saying and I'm paraphrasing someone
could find this if they're listening he
said someone near the to the near to the
extent of like not only are these people
that are the protesters like the ones
that are unlawful but those that are
supporting it as well and like when you
start to see stuff like that that's when
people need to seriously wake up like I
don't care what your politics are but
when you see someone saying like Okay
those people are wrong they should be
silenced they don't have the right to
protest or shut down a street whatever
whatever but then when you hear someone
start to say you can't even affiliate
with those people
it's getting into some weird territory
and I don't think whatever your politics
are I think you should really take note
of that because just being affiliated
with someone and that's like breaking
the law
it's pretty interesting all the phone
carriers that are are giving the
truckers phone access right like how far
does that go it's always these vague
statements like what does that mean like
what exactly does that mean to you I saw
a funny meme I don't want to highlight
his story because I think it really is
relevant from timcast.com first I'll
give you this Justin Trudeau invokes
emergency powers and ever to stop
protests Trudeau's government has
declared the ability to freeze bank
accounts and suspend the the rig
Insurance of truckers involved in the
freedom Convoy wow now that's the story
which is the precursor to the actual
story here
I was browsing Reddit as I often do most
of you know I'm you know flipping
through Reddit all the time when I come
across political Compass memes I'm a fan
they've got 533 000 members and I see
this it says Canada what have you done
and it shows vosh's tweet for those that
are familiar vosh is a socialist
YouTuber and then it says Tim Poole
retweeted
and I'm like I don't understand what is
this and I look down and they have a
stone toss comic in the first panel it
shows me which they call me libertarian
right and vosh a leftist and he reached
out his hand we shake hands and then we
look over at Trudeau who looks like some
kind of Hunchback Goblin or whatever but
uh the comments are then filled with
people saying Tim pool is lib Center not
lib right but I think it's funny uh vosh
tweeted Trudeau explaining to his people
how revocation of citizenship is the
only way to protect Canada from the
Striking Dairy Queen workers and it's a
really good tweet hilarious and then it
shows the ing sock 1984 Big Brother all
that stuff and I thought it was a
fantastic tweet from vosh and so I
retweeted it and I was like yeah right
on and then he makes a bunch of other
points following up on that thread where
he's like how are you all not getting it
that if they can freeze your bank
without a court order if you ever stage
a general strike or try and stand up
against these big corporations or the
power of government they will freeze you
out I find that really funny as much as
I agree with vosh in that point I'm like
dude the vaccine minutes are worse than
that yeah the vaccine minutes are like
we can take away your money and you're
like fine I'll go you know I'll figure
out another way to make money but the
vaccine minutes are you can't enter any
of these buildings unless you inject
this into your body you have no bodily
autonomy yo if someone came to me and
said you have two choices we can take
away your bodily autonomy and inject
things into you against your will or you
can't use a bank I'd be like yo I'll
figure out something else you got
Bitcoin I got crypto I'll barter I'll
whittle a sailboat on a piece of wood
and trade it to someone in exchange for
a cheeseburger yeah but if you're if
it's vax mandate you can't even go
inside the building to try and trade
your little wooden sailboat so I don't
understand how all of a sudden watch is
like this is the line for me you can't
take my money it's like but you're okay
with them injecting people against their
will well look at least on the one thing
we can agree so I will say the meme is
great showing that whatever different
factions we have here everybody is
unhappy with Trudeau and think it's it
thinks it's really really bad I will add
though the responses to vash's tweet you
got a lot of people on the left who are
like you're wrong on this it's good what
he's doing of course yeah as I was
mentioning earlier just pull up any one
of Justin Trudeau's most recent you know
uh cycle of deranged tweets check out
those comments from Canadians that are
in support of him like a full-on I mean
complete salute support of whatever
their great prime minister wants to do
I'm looking for the Abraham Lincoln
Justin Trudeau uh metaphors where
they're like sometimes you have to
suspend habeases right right yeah yeah
that connection's there yo man if if
this is the direction we're going into
they're the ones who radicalize they
they want to accuse their political
opponents of being the ones that
radicalize people but that's exactly
what they do because we know they accuse
of what they're doing but you know I
know a lot of people listen and it's
like why why does this
political side always get to do that
like they get to accuse their political
opponents of doing exactly what they do
but at the same time like that's their
art like they they use all these
buzzwords they slander they say you're
this they say you're that and what that
does is it radicalizes people to do
stuff and take actions like when this
all first started you guys remember the
viral photo that went out of the guy
with a face mask on literally try to run
someone over in the trucker Convoy in a
jeep turned out to be like an antifa
affiliate or something something like
that like that's what I'm saying is like
this this this is this is dangerous like
when we all talk about like rhetoric and
talk about when people are talking about
certain things like there's freedom of
speech we understand that but they're
the ones that use these buzzwords to get
people radicalized where it actually
turns into real world violence and they
don't say a word about it they just Let
It Go by because they're Justified
they're justified in their own minds
because if you're a terrorist then you
have every right to protect yourself
because they're going to hurt you and
your family somewhere somewhere down the
line because they're the scary Truckers
they're the ones that radicalize people
that's what I didn't get is you're
supposed to protect other people's
rights until they're proven guilty
that's so why all of a sudden just
because some the word terrorist gets
involved do they not do we not protect
their rights anymore I don't like that
that's a new things as of like 2001.
yeah a lot of people pointed out how
scary it was I was listening to Dave
Smith on uh Joe Rogan did you guys
listen to that one of course Dave's
great yeah he was just uh he was talking
about Brian stelter and he was saying
that you know misinformation is
dangerous and putting out a story
claiming that certain tragic events
didn't happen is dangerous and then Dave
Smith is like Barack Obama signing the
indefinite detention provision and the
media not covering it is dangerous yes
and it's like yeah man he is that's true
yeah
laser focused yeah a lot of people don't
know this was back I think in like 2012
Obama signed into uh law the National
Defense authorization act which included
a provision that said the US Government
Can detain you
anywhere on the planet without charge or
trial and it should have been the you
know the biggest news the
anti-establishment anti-authoritarian
types are screaming about at the
activists I made a video about it way
back in the day and uh Brian Setter's
scared angry that people are posting
nonsense on on social media so that's
what you get when you when you're from
CNN but uh but look nobody watches CNN
their ratings are in the gutter and this
is exactly why and that's the point Dave
was making he was like you have to have
you ever self-reflected and asked
yourself why it is people believe these
these YouTube videos or believe these
these you know conspiracy videos why is
it they don't trust you anymore it's
because you don't tell the truth because
you're not talking about things people
care about right so you're not
interesting but more importantly it's
because you lie and you spend
CNN just spends all of their time
telling you like why you shouldn't
Listen to Somebody rather than just like
telling the truth in it itself or even
like presenting the truth as like a
counter argument to whoever they're
trying to debunk they just like sit
there and they tell you who's dumb who's
stupid you shouldn't listen to their
right wing and they're just like not a
credible Source it's like if that's
become your news organization you're no
longer a news organization you just have
a very very strong opinion which is fine
but don't call yourself a reliable
source right yeah
it's ridiculous dude it's like literally
ridiculous at this point because like at
one point you know I want people to ask
themselves like are you offended by this
like do I need CNN to lecture me about
what's true and what's not like am I too
stupid to think for myself like why
don't people ask themselves these
questions especially with the whole Joe
Rogan thing it's ridiculous dude like
why why is Brian stelter triggered that
Joe Rogan used the n-word it's like dude
who cares someone told him to be
triggered about it exactly who cares at
this point if Joe Rogan used the n-word
because like who who gets exclusive
rights to a certain word listen if if
you are a certain color if you are a
race and you you literally declare that
I have exclusive rights to a certain
word because of my racial superiority
you're a racist I don't care what color
you are if that's your thinking that's
what you are and I know a bunch of black
people are going to be triggered but I
don't care at this point all the white
Liberals are going to be triggered I got
to correct you it's going to be the the
white the white the white liberals it's
always a the white liberals that are up
in my comment section oh you don't know
you don't know that I'm like dude no
nobody cares it's funny Joe Rogan's
funny who cares it's the people how come
you guys didn't care before I'm pretty
sure how long have those clips you had
Robert Malone on the show how long have
those clips of Joe Rogan been in
existence that that was the interesting
thing I think I think it was uh Brian
Seltzer to let that slip through he was
just like the only I'm paraphrasing but
he was just like the reason that this
video of the n-word is resurfacing is
because of his vaccine misinformation
like he literally just kind of like gave
the game away yeah the whole con you
know and I mean he's right he actually
like said something that was truthful
the vaccine stuff that they're trying to
push isn't working and they they
isolated Joe Rogan they were just like
let's attack other things that he said
there was a period there was a period
for several years where I felt like uh
you know the mainstream corporate press
was just a miserable job they had to be
corrected and called out not this point
what I'm seeing so few people actually
watch them I'm like maybe we shouldn't
even bother talking about them because
now it's just punching down yeah it's
like that's true let's be real they're
not trustworthy people don't trust them
people don't watch them I mean YouTube
forces CNN down people's throats and
Rachel Maddow still plays well for the
the Boomer or crowd but uh the Boomer
crowd's aging out of uh of relevance of
our society you know and you know just
to be light about it but they're they're
no longer in the workforce they're
they're they're moving out of the
workforce they're moving out of the
voting pool for some reason there still
are elected representatives but the
boomers are kind of Aging out gen xers
will be aging out 15 20 years completely
out Millennials will be here for some
time gen Z is Aging in and at this point
I'm just like yo if we're not watching
this stuff and they've become irrelevant
and the only people they're relevant too
are the people who aren't as active as
as the rest of us
I think at a certain point you cross
that Hill you know what I mean you're
climbing uphill challenging the
mainstream press and then one day you
realize they're just not relevant to
this world anymore yeah that is kind of
a soft rule that I have with Newsroom
when I speak to our journalists is um
you know because a lot of times we'll
pitch stories about oh well CNN did this
deranged thing today or MSNBC had this
ridiculous comment today it's just like
generally speaking I don't think we
should be covering corporate press
unless it's something especially
egregious and especially insane sure um
because I mean it would be endless and
I've had that conversation with our
writers it's just like it would just be
an endless cycle of like psycho says
this and do we have to cover psycho says
this and I mean we can't really do that
um except for one writer who is
especially triggered by anything that
Leanna Nguyen says and I am too so it's
just like all right let's see what
Leanna Nguyen said she's she's a Barack
I mean Dave Smith is also talking about
this with Rogan Rogan brought it up that
she's saying like unvaxed people
shouldn't be allowed to leave their
homes yeah yeah but you know I hear that
and I'm listening to it and it's funny
but at a certain point I'm like does it
matter anymore yeah I agree if if we get
to the point where the truckers are just
going to do their thing and Trudeau
can't stop it we get to the point where
we all wake up one day and say Joe Biden
is not relevant to my life
Trudeau for those in Canada not relevant
to my life what matters is what we have
faith and what we have confidence in and
uh this system ain't working you know
what I mean so if if people just woke up
one day and said I'm not going to comply
or participate in your garbage I'm going
to do my own thing it would change
instantly and you look at what's
happening now this is funny it was you
know I remember it was a month or two
ago when I when Luke was here and I said
I think the mandates are going to get
worse I think they're going to lock down
hard and Luke said he didn't think so I
think I think I had a good reason to
think that uh Frederick County for
instance and just reintroduced Mass
mandates they were trying to bring them
back but the the pushback was too great
and I didn't count on that you know
maybe I was a little too pessimistic
Luke had that one right you look at
what's happening in Canada now all of a
sudden uh DC who just started putting in
place as mandates goes oh we're getting
rid of all of all the mandates are gone
now Frederick county is now pulling
their mandate back after what a month
because they realized it wasn't working
anymore no one cares and if no one cares
guess what happens
you've got to maintain this facade that
you have power
and that if you do something people will
obey it but if they enact this mask
mandate and no one obeys it and half the
people in Frederick County weren't doing
it it's in Maryland by the way yeah then
all of a sudden people start to realize
hey wait a minute
the government can't do anything about
anything I mean take a look at speeding
for instance everybody speeds literally
everyone to the point where you're
you're never going to get for the for
the most part you get singled out but
everybody speeds you don't get pulled
over why because there's not enough cops
to pull everybody over when they're
speeding about five miles over limit and
the wonderful thing is if everyone's
speeding together it's safer to speed
you actually get a ticket for going the
speed limit at that point if it's a 60
mile an hour Zone and everyone's going
80 you better be going 80. because
that's that's how you drive safe and the
cop will pull you over if you're not
going the speed of traffic but what
you're saying is it's happening at scale
in Ottawa I mean there was there was an
unnamed Source I forget which Canadian
Outlet it was reported in but an unnamed
Source in the police department says
that they're paralyzed yeah they said
they're totally Paralyzed by what's
happening in the streets of Ottawa with
this protest and that's right there's
there's nothing that they can literally
do about it there's too many people
speeding so if we get to the point where
people keep leaving cities they start
moving out the middle of nowhere if more
and more people start learning how to be
responsible for themselves then
eventually we could wake up one day and
there's just some pathetic shell of a
federal government we don't pay
attention to
that's a really warm soothing thought
isn't it
libertarian Spectrum Rejoice yeah
I think I think it's like the general
public like how many photos of Gavin
Newsom do you need to see with him
without a mask on at a gathering with
thousands of people or with Magic
Johnson and mayor Eric Garcetti and like
how many how many of these do you need
to see that like hey this isn't this
isn't actually the reality they're
claiming it really how many judges do
you have to see that wear white wigs
before you realize what a facade this is
right now are Judges wearing white
people wear like big costumes and stuff
when they're when they're adjudicating
and like all over the world they do this
weird well Elementary crap to make them
stand out I think Ian just rolled rolled
uh two two twenties that wasn't just a
20 and that was double that was that was
double confirm the crit yeah confirmed
correct I gotta tell you man
uh the the suit wearing you know there
was it
I just think people are desperately
trying to to put on fronts yes to
justify what they're doing and that's so
much of what our civilization and
Society is everybody wear your suit and
I I don't wear suits I don't have a suit
I'm not going to wear a suit and I just
don't see the point why gotta weigh your
tie why it covers your buttons so what
why wear suits look I get it if there's
like a kind of
um
you know you're trying to look nice but
I don't think we're in that period
anymore where people need to put on
pretense but you look at judges and
their robes and everything's you know
proper and doctors and their lab coats
and I'm just like dude I don't care for
any of that it doesn't prove anything to
me any random dude can put on a suit and
claim to be someone important it doesn't
fly I guess for for a random person it
might for me it doesn't do anything you
come to me wearing a suit means nothing
to me at all badges are like that too I
don't like that you put a little marker
on your shirt and all of a sudden you're
supposed to have some control over me
like you better be a better person than
me if you want some control over me well
that's that's a different question I
mean that we're talking about uh
policing I'm not saying the institution
is a problem but I'm saying the fact
that they get to just to put a badge on
all of a sudden that gives them power
it's like putting on a suit and you
think that they're more valuable now
because they're wearing a suit I don't
care what you're wearing well no I think
it's their job that grants them certain
you know authorities it's really the gun
that gives them the authority of course
no no no no no it's the it's the gun
control combined with the Monopoly on
violence from the state yeah the state
is a gun gun so it's the fact that they
have many many guns select fire guns
people with armor and Shields and you're
not allowed to have any of those things
and they'll tell you what to do and you
better do it or else yeah but they come
with the badge and it's like even if you
don't see the gun it's just the threat
of the gun this badge means that I have
authority the costume is still very
compelling base yeah I mean I don't say
that because I I respect authority right
now but I'm I'm borderline man well
let's let's let's let's let's have a
little bit of fun here so I still have
this political Compass memes thing
pulled up for those aren't familiar the
political Compass is the authoritarian
Spectrum on the top the libertarian
Spectrum on the bottom then you have the
left spectrum and the right spectrum and
you can be any portion of it so in this
comic where they're talking about me and
vosh vosh is sent he's he's a leftist a
general leftist which means he's
authoritarian and libertarian to a
certain degree whereas they view me as
just libertarian right but a lot of
people started responding saying Tim
pool is lib Center not lib right
what does any of this mean what does lib
right mean what does lib right what does
live left I I said this before and
political Compass memes took something
from one of my videos and put it on and
post it to their Reddit and it like
reached the top of their page where I
said the libertarian left spectrum is
not the authoritarian woke crowd that
demands you adhere to trigger words and
warnings and that you honor pronouns
that's authoritarianism that's adhere to
our culture else lib left is the people
who are like we agree with a Cooperative
system like hippies living on a farm and
one hippie walks in and says hey man I
just grew a bunch of watermelons would
you like to share it with me no problem
dude and you know what I'm gonna do the
dishes because you helped with the
Watermelons there's no transaction
there's no there it's all Cooperative
whereas you know the the liberight
Spectrum would be like I have grown
these watermelons five dollars the other
guy says wonderful it's an excellent
price but I'll tell you what I'll give
you four dollars and I'll trade you the
Satchel of beans that's more Libra I
suppose but for some reason whenever it
comes to the political special people
keep pushing the lie that the
libertarian left is woke yo woke people
are crazy authoritarian they tell you to
adhere to their cause or else yeah
yeah but that strain does run in the
libertarian party does it not what
strain of wokeness like there is an
infection of openness in the libertarian
party that's the liberal libertarian
parties itself yeah yeah I don't know
what the libertarian party is because
they're like open borders
yeah yeah I don't know what's going on
with those guys yeah lib is an
interesting word because I thought you
meant um liberal left it was like left
means liberal but it's lib return that
doesn't mean liberal
I think you got to understand that none
of it means anything to me man
anybody to be honest so left and right
have their root in the French Revolution
the people sitting on the left people
sitting on the right nowadays it doesn't
mean anything you know so you'll get
these like uh like vosh for instance
called me a conservative like I don't
think you know what a conservative is if
that's what you think the the political
factions in this country are so it's
it's so fractured that on the surface
people can't see anyone else's political
ideologies the way I describe it is if
imagine you're in a Big Field this
literally happened uh in Boston and
um there's a left side of the field and
a right side of the field if you're
standing on the left and you look
towards the right side you'll see this
big mass of people one guy's got a
Confederate flag one guy's got a trump
flag one guy's got an American flag and
one guy's got a Nazi flag and you go man
look at all of those crazy people over
there but if you actually were to take
an overhead view you'd see the American
flag guy is actually close to the middle
of the field the Nazi guys all the way
in the far Fringe end no one wants to
talk to him but when you're looking at
it from one perspective one angle all
you'll see is the flags next to each
other because they're actually spaced
far apart and that's exactly what's
happening so
for a lot of people on the right they
looked at their left and they see a big
mass of people they're actually
relatively far away from each other the
same is true for the left however the
left having control of cultural
institutions it's more of a mainstream
corporate press perspective anyone to
the left of Mao is far right alt-right
or whatever you end up with people like
vosh saying well Tim pool is a
conservative and by necessity a racist
and it's just like bro I'm not a
conservative I thought in addition to
politics being so fractured and
challenging to locate who's where and
who identifies as what you get like I
think it was Libs of tick tock or
somebody they'd show like one person
would be like I'm not touching That
vaccine that Trump's rushing out and
then when Biden gets in office early
definitely do what the President says
because I love him and it's like that is
less political Spectrum more cult
worship if you're a cult worshiper you
just fly all over the political spectrum
because you don't have any value real
like personal value yeah that was
probably defiant elves yes defiant L is
one of my favorite uh Twitter accounts
you know I like I like that explanation
because when you kind of get more into
like the cultish type of Lane you know
when you deal with Cults like real Cults
right like people that have like these
insane religious beliefs most of the
time these people don't even realize
what they're actually doing or what
they're believing they've just been told
what to believe they've been told what
to do they've been told what their
actions should be and there's really no
like root to their Doctrine it's just
this is what the hive mind has taught me
this is what the leader has taught me
this is what everyone else around me and
is on the same wavelength and so when we
gravitate towards one thing it doesn't
have to make sense it's just what we're
all doing at the time when we gravitate
toward another thing it doesn't have to
make sense we just we just do it because
that's what we need to do and that's why
I think when people watch this you look
at the political spectrum and
predominantly on the far left none of it
makes sense it's just like this cultish
mentality where we go from one thing to
the other and it it really it's not
educational there's nothing about it
that's intellectual it's just all over
the place it's emotional it's just one
thing to the other and I think that type
of thinking I think what Ian is saying
is I told and that's exactly how cult
mind thinking works the problem with
conservatives people on the right is
that like like any person they assume
that everyone else has the same
perspective as they do but maybe a lack
of knowledge or something like that and
so what they do people do this they
project how they think and feel on other
people and then they say if I know this
you certainly know it that means you're
a liar
what they don't understand is that the
left is an amorphous blob it is
typically you know the establishment
left and many of the leftists who
support them there are authoritarians
they're they're cult-like and they have
no real principles or causes behind them
other than being a part of the hive so
the other day before we were getting on
the show I was talking with Daniel
Turner who we've had we've had on uh
periodically he was on yesterday
and I said that uh abortion is a strong
moral issue for the right and it is not
for the left any any we argued about he
said no no no no no you were wrong the
left will absolutely protest for for
abortion and I said they'll protest for
anything and they don't know what
they're protesting for you go out to the
March for our lives and they can even
tell you what a caliber is they'll
they'll be like well I think we should
ban 28 caliber Chinese guns I'm like bro
you just watch The Dark Knight because I
was watching the other night I don't
know if you saw that scene where Harvey
Dent grabs the gun he's like 28 caliber
so that's not a thing but these people
they have no idea what they're talking
about these guys in Hollywood make a
movie and they make up a number that
makes no sense bro you couldn't have
asked somebody's one person so what I
said was listen
like abortion is a good example of a
strong moral issue versus a cult
strong moral issue for the right and the
pro-life crowd is that they view
abortion as literal murder and I think
Louis C.K had a bit about this where
he's like man if I thought people were
killing babies I'd be pissed off too
so you asked someone who's pro-life how
do they feel about this and they'll be
like it's literal murder you ask someone
left how they feel about it and they'll
say it's like flushing garbage down the
toilet
is there is is there any point where a
regular person in this country if if you
saw someone about to flush a wadded up
piece of garbage into a toilet would you
go no only if there's a septic system
and try and stop them yeah if it was in
a septic system I'd be like hold on is
it biodegradable is that toilet paper
what if you saw someone about to murder
a baby
99.99999 of people would scream and be
like that's a horrifying sight to behold
but if the left doesn't view it as such
they don't care about it so all you got
to do is look at the Kavanaugh protests
when they're banging on the door the
Supreme Court's screaming claiming
they're worried about Roe v wait no
they're not look I get it they're
pro-choice they are but on a scale of
one to ten they're they're they're in
terms of it being a strong moral issue a
10 is a strong moral issue and a one is
you know it's an issue for for the
pro-life crowd it's like a four maybe a
three and for the I'm sorry for the pro
choice crowd it's like a four or three
for the pro-life crowd it's like a nine
or a ten like killing another human
being is wrong so when I see these
people marching on the streets screaming
the top of their lungs it's fascinating
to me
because most of them don't actually care
all that much about what this is and
then you look at the right and they care
substantially more but they're not even
protesting I mean March March for Life
is actually really really large but the
right is substantially less likely to
protest for these issues uh don't ask me
why but I think you know the point I'm
trying to get to is I've been to many
left protests they could not tell you
what it was about they they can't and I
understand you go to some of these
right-wing rallies and they'll give you
a bunch of disparate answers it's really
easy to find stupid people
I've been to many right wing rallies I
went around in 2015 and 16 to all the
Trump rallies when he was running and I
got answers from everybody I remember I
was in Janesville Wisconsin I walked
with some young guys and you know we're
they're talking about hey you mind if I
ask some questions like what are you
here for why are you supporting Trump
and they were like in their early 20s
and they were like political correctness
man it's really really bad they said
what we're seeing with our culture in
terms of canceling people and this is
like 2015-16 they're like in terms of
taking over movies and games and just
making this weird creepy politics stuff
we need someone who's going to speak
their mind and set that that cultural
standard that you can be offensive and I
was like oh okay wow I understand that
I talked to uh in Janesville again I
talked to an older guy and he said he's
like look my factory shut down they
shipped it over overseas and Donald
Trump he's gonna he's gonna be bringing
you back you know he wants to bring
these these jobs back I go to these
left-wing protests and rallies
nothing
Trump's a fascist he Trump's a fascist
we got to stop fascism and I'm like is
there something you think Hillary
Clinton's going to bring to the table no
truth be told the Bernie Sanders people
had demands and it was very similar to
the Trump supporter demand so a lot of
the Bernie people I talked to were like
you know not not the violent ones you
know the actual rally people they were
like he's talking about health care he's
talking about college and he's talking
about union workers I like all these
things and I'm like okay that I
understand and then Bernie was just like
I'd rather have a million dollars and
four houses how many houses does he have
three yeah I think it's three yeah
that's a lot of houses nice houses too
yeah yeah and he's like maybe you could
sell the best you know sell a book and
you could be a millionaire too or
whatever so well it kind of just to
Pivot very briefly back off of that to
something that Ian was saying earlier it
does come down to Clarity of message
when it comes to activism and advocacy
and I saw it like a very because there
were a lot of well uh
s lib takes crap lib takes on Twitter
about the the yeah ish lib takes about
the the trucker uh protest and it was
driving me crazy because there was a
clear distinction because people were
saying like oh well you I'm sure you're
okay with BLM protests then but there
was such a distinction there that I
thought was so obvious at least it was
to me BLM was out there saying people
were saying what do you want BLM and
they were saying we have to reimagine
structures of society we have to
dismantle and and disembowel and take
apart and drag down and stop systemic
racism and it sounds like you're talking
to a religious zealot it makes no sense
you ask a trucker what the problem is
stop the mandates period period I mean
yes at a larger level they're advocating
for freedom but that is a very clear
message that's a very clear ask and
that's what they're after stop the
mandates and that you know you got the
Canadian government that's pivoting
you've got them sending out their own
State media just saying you know we
heard that they might be taking away
your kids I don't know if that's going
to happen or just saying it could and
you're you see these truckers are
getting really upset there was that one
video that we covered this guy was
saying are you saying they're going to
take away our kids they're like I'm not
saying that that's just something I
heard you know so they're trying all
these tactics to kind of break down this
very clear protest that's just asking
for the mandates to be lifted so these
people can feel like they have some
sense of Freedom you heard that the
government's threatening to take away
the children of the protesters State
media well I mean CBC you know Canada
broadcasting whatever they they sent a
reporter out on the on the ground and
this reporter was basically just like
we've heard that potentially your
children could be in danger for being in
this involved in this and it got one of
these truckers got really upset he's
just like wait a second what did you
hear because they because the trucker
knows that the media in Canada basically
represents the federal government and he
got really upset and he said what did
you hear what are you talking about
you're saying that my children my
teenage children that are with me right
now are in danger being taken away by
the government they were just like well
I'm not saying that I don't know what's
going to happen I'm just that's just
what I heard you know that's just one
example of the games that the media is
playing in Canada you know to try to
like break down this protest that has
very clear demands unlike the BLM
protests which had abstract you know
cosmological demands that can't be met
in reality so I think there's a major
distinction there clear messaging versus
abstract messaging yeah the abstract
messaging is just cult yes yes they
don't know what they're fighting for yep
that's exactly they're banging on the
doors the Supreme Court they're
screaming and they don't know for what
reason or at least at the very least not
a particularly strong issue I think most
of these protests are just bored virtue
signals it's young people who are like
what are we doing today it's like are
you going to come to the protest sure I
guess oh yeah the BLM riots was like
let's get out of the house kovitz got us
all locked up we have a chance to take
our masks off and go crazy it's like
let's let's party man burning man got
canceled that's what that was right
right yeah yeah Coachella got canceled
we'll have our own and that's that's
that's it
you know it takes a lot to see the right
come out in protest and they've started
doing it more and more
and it's been and it's effective
and it shows you that uh the political
establishment has used protest
to their advantage for some time now it
shows you that BLM is effectively an
apparatus of the state when they go out
and they Riot and they get funding for
it it's fine when Kamala Harris uses
GoFundMe or whatever to raise money for
people who are criminals that's all fine
when truckers of their own volition say
honk honk terrorism freeze their bank
accounts shut them down take their kids
maybe even put guns or something who
knows what they're going to do enact
emergency Powers never before used
wow
what's crazy about the BLM stuff too is
like not only did they do worse like in
2020 but that's actually when like the
lockdowns were you see what I'm saying
like that was actually during the time
of where there was a lot of question
marks around covet and we didn't have
that much information and it was like
that's when things were locked down and
the federal government was more loose
with them but here we are two years
later things are starting to loosen up
but it's as if we were in 2020 and this
just started that's how that's how
aggressive they are like no no you
cannot we you have to get vaccinated no
no we have to do this because it's going
to kill everybody you see what I'm
saying like that that contrast when you
make it is is
it's it's crazy yeah when England
basically repeals all their mandates I
mean England's back to base zero now
it's as if there'd be I believe they're
like pre-pandemic situation like as if
it's just an open Society now but then
for Canada who's one of the common part
of the Commonwealth to not it doesn't
make any sense yeah like what are they
waiting for
what they're waiting for but during the
pandemic BLM could walk around and write
and do whatever they want as long as
they don't step on federal property if
they'd went to the White House BLM
they'd be we'd see thousands of them in
prison right now it's not true because
they actually did go to the White House
and they broke windows and they set the
church on fire and they also went to
some of the federal courthouses and like
I think it was Portland and they set the
thing on fire they were tearing down the
fences around it people had to evacuate
so they did set foot on Federal Land and
Trump received a lot Tom Cotton if
you'll recall he uh the editorial
director at the newspaper fill in the
blank I don't remember which one it was
resigned because of Tom Cotton's
editorial calling for federal
intervention in these mobs and riots
that were going on and this is something
that act blue and Kamala Harris were
supporting at the time that was fine
that was great ocasio-cortez was saying
that this is designed to make you
uncomfortable now it's happening in
Ottawa these people of terrorists this
is in Nationwide Insurrection Q Anon is
running rampant in the streets it's
mind-boggling to watch and I really hope
it read pills a bunch of people but
Lydia they were wearing masks so
this store actually came out right
around the time we went live this crazy
stuff
project Veritas has released expose FDA
part one FDA executive officer on hidden
camera reveals future covid policy quote
Biden wants to inoculate as many people
as possible have to get an annual shot
they say
food FDA executive officer Christopher
Cole inadvertently revealed that his
agency will eventually announce that
annual covid-19 vaccinations will become
policy
Cole is an executive officer heading up
the agency's counter measures and
initiatives which plays a critical role
in ensuring that drugs vaccines and
other measures to counter-infectious
disease and viruses are safe he made the
revelations on hidden camera to an
undercover reporter Cole indicates that
annual covid-19 shots isn't probable but
certain when pushed on how he knows an
annual shot will become policy coal
States just from everything I've heard
the FDA are not are not going to not
approve it the footage is part of a
two-part series and the FDA also
contains sound bites from coal about the
financial incentives pharmaceutical
companies like Pfizer have to get have
to get the vaccine approved saying quote
it'll be recurring found recurring
Fountain of Revenue it might not be that
much initially but it'll recurring if
they can if they can get every person
required at an annual vaccine that is a
recurring return of money going into
their company
quote they're going they're all approved
under an emergency just because it's not
as impactful as some of other approvals
really an emergency for kids so there's
a lot more to this
um I've seen a little bit of it
but it seems this guy at least believes
uh
it's your yearly coverage recurring
Fountain of Revenue monetizing your body
with inoculations dude medical
subscription Services Biden wants to
inoculate everyone is that what that guy
said everyone Biden has says he has said
that himself I forget which I forget
which press conference it was but his
solution to this coveted problem was we
have to vaccinate everyone in this
country and then we have to vaccinate
the rest of the world that was his that
was his way out of this I'm struggling
to find the uh the exact question I
remember that I remember that he did say
that right okay all right thanks for
doing a little sanity check on me there
because I remember that yes no he said
that was his one year I think
yeah no he said it that's his goal
that's that's how he thinks the virus
shut down look up the definition of the
word inoculate and think that Joe Biden
wants to do this to you it's so to
implant microorganisms or infectious
material into a culture medium to
introduce a serum vaccine or antigenic
substance into the body of a person oh
like say it like that yeah this third
one is 200 plant microorganisms or
infections I mean that's basically you
know you put you put a little bit of
dangerous stuff in the body so it jacks
up an immune response and then you
become immune over time is the idea but
forcing it on people top down medicine
it's crazy what did it say it's a
reoccurring revenue is that what yeah
there it is a fountain it'll literally
monetize your body the experimental
solution service yes man you gotta you
gotta look these pharmaceutical
companies pay big for sponsoring these
big corporate media they spend a lot of
money lobbying they make a lot of
contributions how many pharmaceutical
commercials ran on the Super Bowl do you
guys get a number
I know that all these big media
companies are brought to you by Pfizer
because I saw that that's a great
Supercut uh in the meantime I want to
say so the old uh tried phrase is all
roads lead to Rome I wonder if the
phrase for our culture that survives for
centuries is all roads lead to Alex
Jones
yes
is that right through Alex through Alex
Jones I love that
was uh that story the other day about
the BLM activist who tried assassinate
the Democrat there and people are
pointing out that Alex Jones had said
several months ago that there's going to
be attacks on Democrats to justify gun
control and harsh measures against the
people
I gotta say if you
if you throw spaghetti at enough clocks
eventually they'll tell you the right
time or yeah you know whatever twice
today whatever yeah yeah throw spaghetti
no you throw spaghetti in a bunch of
clocks and eventually some of them will
just splatter into the right time yeah
yeah so if you make if you're making
predictions on everything eventually
people can be like theoretically I think
of a million monkeys of a million
typewriters that eventually write Hamlet
right right as the saying goes uh
Hamlet no that did that to that demo it
was a mayor yeah
mayoral candidate Merrell candidate
imagine if that was a white guy that did
something like that that story is Crazy
by the way too I I watched the press
conference apparently he walked in and
they're like can we help you and he
pulled the gun out from a few feet away
and fired and missed wow it's funny
because I saw a lot of people on Twitter
saying I call BS how did he miss and I'm
like that sounds like someone who's ever
fired up yeah handgun yes it's like the
Waukesha stuff just gets not a movie
right under the rug did the guy see was
he looking him in the eyes like was a
guy able to oh he said that the guy
walked in and just you know pulled a gun
point did it but uh people who think you
can't miss have clearly never fired a
handgun very easy to miss the handgun
very easy people when they fire when
they squeeze their hand they move the
gun in certain ways they don't realize
it and so what ends up happening is they
usually Point left or right or if you're
right-handed you'll point left and down
or something like that at least that's
what I was told when I went to the range
the first time and it happened to me
telling me how to how to shoot properly
but yeah I think it's just getting crazy
out there for a variety of reasons when
you have these disparate factions of
people that are all extreme
no cohesion just
eventually
well I am I am concerned because there
does seem to be a shortage of actual
right-wing terrorism which means that
you're going to need to find a way to
meet the demand you know what I mean
like if people aren't being violent
that's what makes me think that the this
cache of guns in Canada might possibly
be some kind of bad really truly might
be a bad actor trying to make them look
bad trying to plant this on them and
make it look like they're trying to plan
some kind of violent this is a
well-known guy I mean this is an
activist who did this could you imagine
well okay he's been arrested for the BLM
guy considering they were there and they
watched him do it I think they got the
right guy rest assured Olivia the FBI is
on that oh yeah yeah they're on it
they're on it they're working on it
really hard it happened well in uh
Michigan you know they had outstanding
results the right-wing terrorism will
happen what if your life was there's
nothing bad going on right now why
what's wrong with reality that's
something we can't figure out what's
wrong like something's bad I have a bad
feeling I can't see anything wrong so
they go out like this is the mentality
if something's not wrong then something
must be wrong because life is bad like
these people live to their law
enforcement they go around looking for
people breaking laws
and if the people aren't breaking laws
and they make up new ways to get them
yeah I think it's I think it's a good
strategy to easily emotionally
manipulate a lot of people very quickly
because if you could
bring Unity with like millions of people
with a centralized enemy I think that's
essentially what Trump was
um you could really get a lot of people
unified for a specific cause and I think
you see this happen throughout history
all the time where there's a common
enemy that the people all have and I
think the far left does a really good
job at doing this they would do a really
good job at demonizing their opponents
they do a really good job at slandering
them and painting them as these are the
people that are going to destroy your
life the white supremacist the Neo-Nazi
it's always this fear everything's
that's why everything's a phobia
everything is a phobia homophobia
islamophobia they just slap phobia to it
and we unify the entire base and they're
out there busting people's Doors Down it
it works I like that phobia phobia if
you don't like a sport you're you're
soccer phobia everything's a phobia you
don't like soccer
soccer fear is very powerful you see
what they did
with Dave Chappelle they uh he was uh in
opposition to this um construction that
was going to be going on in his town so
they framed it as though he opposed
affordable housing
because it's always a dirty manipulative
game they didn't ask him why he was in
opposition to it they just said this
proposal would include affordable
housing Dave Chappelle threatens to pull
millions of dollars out of town in
opposition to affordable housing I've
covered enough of those I I melting
brain numbing City Council meetings to
know that the affordable housing that
these City councils advocate for is
almost always corrupt it never pans out
it is all about money it's all about
corrupt politicians I mean I covered
Anaheim there's there's like a super
corrupt problem in Anaheim because
Disney owns Anaheim but and and that's
how these deals go down I mean obviously
Dave Chappelle's no [ __ ] like he's a
sharp guy he probably saw right through
the corruption and right through the
nonsense and he went there and it's just
like I don't support this and they
panicked and then they had to smear him
so does Disney actually literally own
the city of Anaheim uh they they do
through back door deals because without
Disney and without angels Stadium
Anaheim is not a city it's it's like a
third world town so well basically the
city council of Anaheim is never going
to do anything that's not in Disney's
best interest which also puts them in
the ccp's pocket nice wow that checks
out yeah yeah well things are going good
sorry I just want to bring some good
news from California Sunny California
maybe let California go its own way huh
yeah I think it's supposedly going to
slip down isn't it or slip up into
Canada at some point Canada yeah watch
out it's coming for you when the San
Andreas fault yeah
they thought it was going to fall off
and disappear but I think it's
technically sliding up
maybe something like that and then it'll
go right below Alaska and then connect
the yeah
Bridge you know I think if California
didn't move that far north though
everything about California would change
overnight because the people who live
there would be able to handle the harsh
realities
that's one of the things that's so
awesome about the protests in Canada the
truckers is they are just they could
just handle that old man you saw Wall
Street everyone turned in late November
or mid-november whenever it was there it
was cold there was funny posts where uh
some women tweeted you know you should
go out there and and spray water on
their handles and freeze them out and
someone was like to think that Canadian
truckers don't know how to handle ice it
shows exactly what's wrong with these
Urban You Know city Urban liberal types
like yeah if there's if there's anyone I
would ask for advice in terms of ice on
my car it'd be a Canadian trucker
seriously like you guys are in the cold
and you drive know anything I don't know
about tips and tricks about getting the
ice off the car and opening up they'd be
like oh yeah I got you yeah yeah it's
probably happened to you guys winter
comes around your car door freezes shut
you can't open it how do you get in
gotta get that remote start turn the
heat on right that's the secret I was
looking for how many pharmaceutical
commercials they ran during the Super I
cannot find this but if anyone out there
if you guys know feel free to Super Chat
it or leave it in the comments if you
have some ideas or links or something
because I'd like to find out I have a
feeling there were more than last year
yeah I'm sure that's non-zero let's talk
about uh the the the absurdity that is
Hollywood in California and Alec Baldwin
we got the story from timcast.com
cinematographers family files wrongful
death suit against Alec Baldwin the
Santa Fe Sheriff's Office is still
investigating the October 2021 onset
fatality but we have this story from the
New York Post Alec Baldwin sued by the
family of Helena Hutchins
they released a video
it's kind of creepy it is a CGI video
I can only show some of it because
YouTube actually will probably shut us
down if I show you even though it's like
simulated
whatever man it is what it is but I can
you know I can play a certain a decent
amount of it so let's let's play some of
this video
so this is important in understanding
the story about Alec Baldwin and the
shooting of Helena Hutchins let me slow
down and give in prefaces real quick for
those who are not familiar with exactly
what this is Alec Baldwin was on the
filming set of a movie called rust he
shot us in a photographer at first it
was it was declared a misfire it was an
accident we started to get more and more
details and it turns out that um based
on the news and the information that
came out it sounds much more like Alec
Baldwin intentionally murdered this
woman at least
a lot of people refuse to believe it I
certainly think it's more probable than
an accident because Alec Baldwin had a
single action revolver you had to pull
the hammer back you had to pull the
trigger to fire it it was loaded with
live rounds it was given to him by
someone who was not the onset armorer we
had Nick Cersei on the show who had
worked with that armorer before and said
she was great so all of this just keeps
coming back to there's no way there's an
accident but let me give you that one
very very important detail before I show
you this clip
Alec Baldwin claims that after he shot
this woman he didn't know she was hit
for 45 minutes if you're standing in
front of someone and you point a gun at
them pull the hammer back pull the
trigger he claims he didn't pull the
trigger but you pulled the hammer back
and it goes off and then they go uh and
they collapse and two people fall down
what do you do did Alec Baldwin just go
all right and walk away apparently cut
cut away all right everybody and they're
screaming people are screaming she's
dying and he's just like I didn't see
anything
cinematographer acts good yeah right
yeah he thought she was acting are they
filming her is she part of this so
here's let me play this clip now to show
you um some of the some of the context
around here so here's the building
the reason why I think this is important
to go through is because a lot of people
are trying to imagine in their head what
it was like when this woman was shot and
you can see here this is a it's all CGI
by the way this is what the building
looks like all right let's play a little
bit because now they're going to take us
inside the building it's only about a
minute long this video
all right so there's the building we are
now going inside oh I think that was
that actually a photograph hold on oh
cool the first one so this is an actual
switches right it's cool is that a it
looks yeah and then it switches to CGI
there you go all right then we go inside
and this is what it looks like inside uh
this church on the set of this film
Alec Baldwin has handed the gun
by the I guess associate director
assistant assistant director assistant
director
and then uh he sits down he's got the
gun in his uh in his holster and there
he is and I think now they're going to
show they're gonna pan around and you
can now see they're showing you where
the cinematographer was
and where the the uh the other director
right yeah the camera and I don't know
who those other two people are they
weren't named crew so here's what's
interesting I didn't I didn't realize
this
how far away he was from her and the
crowd and that he pointed the gun
straight at her and not the camera
because when we had first talked about
the story I was like why would he point
the gun straight at the camera and
people were like oh maybe it was to get
that shot or whatever she's she's off to
the his left of the camera he pointed
straight at her and he fires he he
killed her he definitely killed her so
you were you were you were arguing with
me about this initially that you can't
say he he killed her I don't know if I
would call it murder the intention is
unknown he definitely pointed the gun at
the woman pulled the trigger and killed
her whether or not he intended to I
don't know but I don't think that really
is what this is all about right now I
mean like look let's up for the courts
to decide let me show you this clip all
right we're not going to actually show
it because YouTube would get mad at us
but he like look at that five feet away
from her
or whatever it was and then he pulls the
hammer back and he shoots her wow now
here's the thing I'm going to skip over
the part where she actually gets it
because that's you know and you can see
people rushing over to help her and
again CGI rendering of what happened
this is not actual video evidence where
did Alec Baldwin go there's no other
exit to this building and he said for 45
minutes he didn't know that she got shot
with a real bullet so he's like I
thought She fainted or something bro no
if you point a gun at someone and you
pull the hammer back and it goes bang
and then someone screams and collapses
why would you assume they must have
fainted he's a weak mind bro and he
wasn't able to accept what just happened
to me yeah dude it was like shock I was
like what happened when the soldier goes
crazy in the trench he knew he killed
her he was shocked no Ian you you that
that you you might as well believe in
aliens or he's just blatantly lying you
might as well believe if you're gonna
tell me that Alec Baldwin pointed a gun
at a person from like five feet away
pull the hammer back it went off in his
hand he felt The Recoil The Recoil of a
live round is different from The Recoil
blank and then the woman screams and the
guy behind her screams as well as they
do in this video and then people run
over to help and he goes must have
fainted and then gets up and walks off
sorry I I would rather believe that
aliens took over his mind with a mind
control device that seems more plausible
to me then he was like I didn't realize
I had just shot them when I pointed I
got it pulled in and pulled the hammer
back and it fired nah he knew what he
did that's why I keep hearing the story
and I'm like why would you assume
anything other than he put a bullet in
the gun and he shot her the who put the
bullet in the gun that one I wonder hold
on bro if you're gonna tell me that it
was the assistant director or someone
else to put the bolt in the gun Alec
Baldwin feeling The Recoil of that live
bullet having trained with Firearms
would have been like what yeah exactly
and then when she clapped and screamed
he would have been like what happened
except you knew my life is over my
career is over and he probably it all
went through his head immediately when
he pulled the trigger and was like it's
too much for my brain
I mean that's a possibility I don't know
if that really happens people are weak
people go crazy no no no what you don't
understand is when someone is in a
shocked moment they don't have
complicated thoughts they have Panic
thoughts and if Alec Baldwin so you guys
ever see Sherlock Holmes you ever see a
game of shadows Robert Downey Jr so good
I love it so they're trying to find out
there's a guy who's got surgery to look
like an ambassador he's trying to
trigger a World War
and so you know he's with Watson and you
know Watson's in the in the room and
they're like how do we find someone
who's pretending to be someone else
and then Sherlock says
you know oh I think it's Watson who's
like
yeah Sherlock's playing chess with
Moriarty and Watson's like do something
shocking because they're trying so hard
to maintain a facade they won't react
properly to a shock and so what he does
is he smacks the tray with champagne on
it the champagne shatters and everyone
in the room goes oh but the one guy in
Disguise doesn't Flinch because in his
mind he's desperately trying to maintain
his Persona so when the shock happens he
doesn't respond properly like everybody
else
so that's when I when I hear this story
when Alec Baldwin himself I mean he lied
about everything he was like she was a
friend she was a friend then he said I
didn't know her I never met her before
it's like this guy's full of it the idea
that he pointed the gun pulled the
hammer back and went off in his hand
first I got so many questions The Recoil
of a live bullet compared to the blank
he knew he was holding it it went off in
his hand the woman screams and falls
down it severed her spinal cord and he's
like I didn't realize it happened and
what did he do get up and walk away yeah
that's that's BS bro listen dude he did
it I don't know I don't know if this is
the same but I mean I I watched Kyle
Rittenhouse shoot somebody and kill them
in self-defense and I didn't pull that
trigger and that had an effect on me
like I will never forget that I will
never watch forget watching that like
the way that I I felt I saw it like I
watched life leave this guy's eyes like
literally like on the floor like so I
just like when I hear like these gun
stories and I can't relate to this like
you know police officers or people in
the military that have actually shot
people I think that would be someone
good to ask you know but for me like
I've I've watched that and I don't see
how Alec Baldwin could come out and just
be like Oh I thought She fainted like I
didn't know there's there's like even if
you're in shot like because I'm gonna be
on honestly when I watched when I
watched that dude get killed I was kind
of like in a state of of shock like I
was still collected I knew what was
going on but I was still kind of like
did I like I put it on Twitter and I'm
like did
I just saw that
like I just saw that like it was just
like in my mind like I it couldn't leave
my mind like I I just don't see how you
could like shoot somebody and just and
then go directly to
I just thought She fainted there's an
Indescribable feeling that I've talked
about before when I see people who get
mutilated or killed and I don't have a
word for it I can't even really describe
it it's a weird feeling
I see I've seen a guy whose legs were
turned to uh well yeah I know I'm not
going to get into it too much detail but
uh I've seen severe injuries mutilation
and death and there is a feeling that
you get watching a body be carried away
maybe it's just me maybe not everybody
definitely not just you no I know and
you know I wonder if there would be a
word for the feeling you get when you
watch this if more people had the shared
experience of witnessing something like
that exorcism I don't know but because
the opposite of an exercise because most
people don't actually expression that
there's no way to explain that word to
someone who's never experienced that
feeling
when I when I hear that Alec Baldwin
pulled out a gun and it went off and
shot and killed a woman and that he just
assumed She fainted I'm like this man is
a liar and knew exactly what he did
because you know what I'll I'll put it
this way
there's a video and read it right now I
love I love saying I'm not read it right
and it's a little girl and she's got a
gun and she's playing with it and she
puts the magazine in and she pulls it
back and Chambers around and then she's
going like oh and she's like playing
with the trigger and laughing and then
she releases the magazine and smiles and
laughs and then bang it goes off because
there's a round in the chamber and she
goes
that's freaking out
when a live round is discharged from a
gun you don't just get up and go must
fainted and walk off
yeah you start freaking out the weird
part is in this video that the after he
fires the video goes dark and then comes
back up and Alex not there like where
did he what happened he must just got up
and walked out then apparently that's
what happened and he was on the phone
yeah he left and he got on the phone and
he said he's lying about all of his the
problem he said I didn't realize she got
hit with a live bullet for 45 minutes I
thought She fainted something like that
but what's bothering me so much about
this whole story is motive
what do you mean what's the motive for
him shooting her the the crew had been
complaining the whole time they had
threatened to walk offset before Alex uh
Alex Alec Baldwin is a hot head who's
gotten into fights with people in the
past I think he just settled a lawsuit I
could be wrong about that and here he is
I think Viva fry had a really great
explanation about this he was like
imagine you're Alec Baldwin seasoned
famous a-lister Wealthy on a low budget
production the industry is in distress
you've got kova and all these rules the
crew is complaining non-stop but
threatening to walk off then you get the
cinematographer who's telling you what
to do but this is not the director you
don't take orders from her but she won't
stop nagging see Alec Baldwin said she
was what do you call her very like
direct or something yeah he wasn't
saying about her that she was um a
friend and nice to work with he said she
was like forceful effectively I think
the motive is simple
he was pissed off she was causing
problems she was jamming up the set and
the perfect opportunity to murder
someone is in a movie set where you're
supposed to have a gun but hold on a
minute in this lawsuit they're like why
I wasn't using a rubber gun why did he
have a live single action revolver with
a with it with with real ammo in it with
a real Bullet at least
when they were when they were doing it
was like test filming
none of it makes sense unless of course
Alec Baldwin was like I am sick of this
woman she is causing problems for my
movie set and the easiest way to kill
somebody is to say it's an onset
accident bang none of his story makes
sense and I'll tell you this I'd be
willing to believe there was a
conspiracy to commit murder between him
and the assistant director before I
believe this was an accident
for this to to have been an accident you
have to believe in magical fairy tales
that the armorer who Alec Baldwin knows
is supposed to be the only one handling
the weapon didn't do it that somehow
live bullets got into it that somehow
Alec Baldwin forgot all of his training
that somehow Alec Baldwin with a single
single action revolver pulled the
trigger back and with his finger out of
uh not on the trigger it went off
because that was testified too by the
assistant director so now you've got a
you've got a broken sear on a single
action revolver that he pulled he pulled
the hammer back his finger was off the
trigger it went off he didn't realize a
bullet was in it despite 40 Years A Plus
of weapons training against someone he
had ever reason to be upset with nah
dude get out of here with that you know
I've been saying this from the beginning
I think he killed that woman I'll I'll
rephrase that I think it is it is
substantially more likely he killed this
woman on purpose then he killed her on
accident so if I stay he did kill her
yeah negligent homicide I think at the
very least
um my I have a very similar take on
yours except that I think he was just
very angry with her and didn't like her
and was fantasizing about killing her
and there had happen to be a bullet in
the gun that's ridiculous it just
doesn't make sense that he would throw
everything away just to try and sneak it
down no he's not throwing it away look
at this he's not even going to be
destroyed his career we don't destroyed
his life dude he's destroyed his life
but yeah okay under your scenario he's
such a psychopath like a total
psychopath that he didn't run even the
most minimal cost benefit analysis or
what he was about to do he's a hothead
but no not a hot head like anybody could
be a little bit of a hot head this guy
must be a psychopath to make that poor
absolutely poor cost benefit analysis or
um or there was a potential for a
lawsuit that was going to cost him more
money
so he shot her I don't know this still
doesn't add up for me I don't know
that's true by several people I'm glad
that it's going to court and I hope that
the in criminal charges yeah we don't
look they are I'll tell you this there
are criminal charges no this is the
first I don't think so this is a civil
case right there's no criminals right
not yet and I'm gonna I'm asking oh yeah
the point is you're saying it's going to
court I'm saying this you're saying it
was a miscalculation what do you mean he
if he walked out up to this woman in the
middle of New York Avenue and pulled out
a gun and shot her he'd be in prison two
18 year olds are sitting there one picks
up a gun and points to the other one and
shoots him and kills him and it's like I
didn't know there was a bullet in it
like we were acting for a movie they'd
be like shut up you're under arrest yeah
if they had a camera on him they thought
they were acting and then Alec Baldwin
doesn't it he doesn't turn us for how
long that's kind of where I'm thinking
is like is it really far-fetched to
believe that Alec Baldwin like
believes that he's above all this yeah
it's not far-fetched I think he does you
see what I'm saying like do you like do
we really sound crazy saying I think
Alec Baldwin thinks he could publicly
get away with murder I saw the sympathy
crap videos he put out in the weeks
following look let me just say
there's a potential for a motive in that
we've we've heard that people are
walking off set that people are
complaining that she was part of the
crew and the crew was really really
upset and it's frustrating for this guy
who thinks he's so big and he's an
a-lister she's not the director but
she's giving him orders and telling him
what to do and he's getting frustrated
those make sense the reality is there
could be an infinite number of reasons
for him out of maybe he had an affair
with her oh no you know Hilaria is going
to find out maybe some it could be it
could be as simple as that we don't know
the fact is the story of how this went
down you'd have to be an absolute [ __ ]
to believe the way they've described it
he was accidentally given the gun by the
wrong person even though even though he
knows and as stated already in
interviews it has to come from the
armorer but he let it come from the
other guy instead and then he took the
gun didn't check it even though he knows
you're supposed to check the gun it's
supposed to be displayed for you he's
stated all of those things he's the one
who said you're handed a gun and it's
they open it up they explain it to you
and then you know if you fiddle with it
in any way so they're like why don't you
check it well if I did check it they'd
take it away from me that makes no sense
like it's an obvious lie but let me just
make it simple for everybody go out to a
shooting range all right
talk to an instructor
have them teach you and and and and and
bring some blanks and fire a blank and
then fire uh you know what what was the
caliber of the gun was was it uh it
wasn't a 45 was it I don't know I don't
know what it was I don't recall but just
just get a difference of the blank and
the real bullet the feel you're gonna be
like wow this one's obviously the blank
and this one's obviously the real gun so
I do think it was a murder just because
he just shot her and apparently had good
enough aim because we just saw in
Louisville Louisville how it's
pronounced this guy attempted to
Louisville
um he attempted to shoot somebody really
close range and still ended up missing
him for Alec Baldwin to hit this lady
dead to rights that looks incredibly
intentional and think about it it was
straight in the center of her chest so
that it hit her spine too yeah that's
intense and went through and hit the
director yeah he shot two people yeah
check this out it went straight to the
center of her chest and through her
spine
so this is we're talking about winning a
lot like winning three lotteries in a
row week after week after week that he
had the wrong gun he wasn't supposed to
be using that he wasn't supposed to
point it at her there wasn't supposed to
be a bullet in it that his finger was
off the trigger and he pulled the hammer
back but the hammer went off anyway and
then the bullet it missed but it went
perfectly into the center of her chassis
and ripped her spine apart then he said
I didn't realize I hit her and got up
and walks away yeah get out of here man
people who you know no I'm not playing
that game he did it he murdered it was
on purpose that's my opinion that is my
opinion
if her family now is it up to them to
press like charges uh they have yeah
that was that was the not the Civil
charges I mean like criminal charges who
charged who files that the state does
and what are they so you think they're
waiting on it because Alec Baldwin's
Alec Baldwin so as everyone's already
predicted Alec Baldwin will pay some
some fat settlement and he'll never see
a day in jail
that's the way it works in this country
well I think that then his motivation
for thinking that he could do it and get
away with it was entirely correct and
that would be perfect motivation to do
that if you got sick of somebody you're
like boy I think I can get away with
this watch me I got an idea for a movie
rust too the making of rust
I'm sure that's coming he'll be the
victim of the movie you know I got to be
honest I'd love to make a really really
um a sketch a really great movie trailer
sketch and bad taste about this
whole thing Russ too the making of Russ
yeah I have no sympathy for this her
husband her family right now if they're
not following through taking this guy
down in his entire production crew
they're suing him I mean taking him down
I don't he has tons of money he'll pay
it out what do you think is what do you
think they're going to do put him in
prison for 30 years hey don't do that
the state does I'm in prison for a year
does this yeah but I mean where's the
pressure from the family where's the guy
standing up and saying he just belongs
in jail he killed my wife
he's thinking I'd rather just get the 60
million dollars you should get both
it's up to him what he wants it's not
gonna come from the family to get to get
legal record
um uh criminal justice
the state decides people need to
understand this um I don't know if it's
true for every state I think it is there
have been so many so many instances
where
someone will file charges look they'll
get attacked and then the police will
arrest a person and they'll file charges
against the the person who got arrested
and then the other person says I don't
want to press charges I want to withdraw
and the cops will be like you aren't
pressing charges we are it's the state
versus Mr Smith not you know Jane Doe
versus John Doe we don't need you as a
witness because we already have your
medical records showing the attack
occurred bye-bye
so it doesn't matter what the
individuals want but typically when
someone refuses to press charges if they
say I don't want to press charge what
they're really saying is I'm not going
to be a cooperating witness for the
state and the state will likely lose
them and so then the state says okay get
out of here we're not gonna we're not
going to move forward there's no
complaint and not to mention that like
do you really want to be a prosecutor
who's like I've got no witness no victim
so it's just conjecture
and I'd rather not file the paperwork to
be completely honest right is that
that's probably what's going to happen
in this lot of work go to court they've
got a lot of eyewitnesses I can't
imagine none of them would testify
considering all of the different
lawsuits against Alec Baldwin and his
company you'd think there'd be criminal
charges against them instantly for doing
this like I don't care what the reason
is but that's what I'm saying it's it's
why I think one of the things about this
is a perfect crime Alec Baldwin wants to
kill someone do it on a movie set you'll
never see it you'll never see a day in
jail rust 2 The Perfect Crime yes I like
that that's pretty good yeah we got to
make that happen and then whenever we
show Alec Baldwin it should be like
grainy black and white with like a
thunderstorm behind him and he's like
yeah
yeah and I'm like Manchester is real big
you know with the lightning striking
behind him
now is your turn to die no oops it was
an accident you know what I will
continue to mock this shooting until
they file criminal charges against that
guy dude it's so crazy man it's it's
it's mainstream celebrity it's political
it's the establishment it's a big club
and you ain't in it but I'm glad to see
that club falling apart to be honest you
know
yeah maybe some things will change I
want to talk about Roblox well no I got
we have this other story I'll just
mention really really quickly from
BuzzFeed a rust crew member texted a
warning about accidental gun discharges
days before Alec Baldwin fatally shot
Helena Hutchins this is super unsafe I
mean we knew the story but the more I
see this stuff the more it just pushes
me towards I think they set this thing
up
like Alec Baldwin's story is so half
brained and like insane and
contradictory then I'm like I see this
and I'm just like
I don't believe any of them
I don't believe any of them man I think
Alec Baldwin
you know so so one thing one thing I
think we just heard recently with Nick
Cersei though is they had a crew and B
crew or something like that because of
covet a b and c yeah so they had you
couldn't be in the same room depending
on your your crew or whatever they could
only be in the room with other A's and B
and C had to be out of the room that can
explain why it was that the armor wasn't
the one who gave the weapon to Alec
Baldwin but it could but it doesn't
explain why Alec Baldwin threw away his
training why he didn't realize he just
shot and killed a person shot dead
center through this chest and through
the spine and he was like I thought She
fainted just like walks away it's like
yeah those are the dead giveaways plus
he's on the phone no no he was on the
phone right away right yeah so what
someone faints so you get on the phone
right away with somebody I don't know if
it was right away how long I don't know
how long between the shooting and him on
the phone but I'm pretty sure there's
pictures of him on the phone outside
like after it happened I don't know if
it was within a minute or within 20
minutes and then he didn't turn his
phone over he refused to turn his phone
over probably because of his
conversation did he eventually do it
exactly yeah along exactly why somebody
called something he was setting up
it has been done do we think of a
conspiracy as starting to make a little
bit more sense I'm actually crying right
now for the cameras they're taking
pictures of me as I'm talking to you
yeah well the conspiracy theory is that
the Selena Hutchins woman was a
journalist before she got involved in
cinematography and she was doing in
these investigations so the conspiracy
theorists think that she was still
actively investigating something and
that she was taken out yeah I don't know
about any of that stuff man that is
interesting I think it's enticing though
yeah I think you got a story of a hot
head movie star he's pun he shoved the
guy in the street and got sued over it
he screamed at his kid and called her a
little piggy pig or something like that
you little pig and so he's known for
having a bad temper
we know the crew is fighting with him
he lied several times about his story
isn't it just a simple solution that
sometimes people commit murder
it's uh
well yeah that is a simple solution
applying it to this is a little more
complicated because we don't know where
the bullet came from I want to know
that's why I'm saying he committed a
murder it came from him he got a bullet
he put it in the gun yeah yeah why was
he using a real gun that's
this you got to get the shot and what I
mean is the camera angle it's got to
look right on cameras the lawsuit is
flat out saying that they have prop guns
for test filming like actual replicas
and rubber guns why was using a real
single action revolver with live ammo in
it okay maybe what happened was uh the
assistant director hated Helena and set
Alec up and and broke the Seer on the
Sierra as the peace inside it holds the
hammer back he broke it on purpose and
that's why he said Alec Baldwin's finger
was off the trigger and he pulled the
hammer back and it went off
on a functioning single action that
wouldn't happen
but maybe it was an old weapon and the
Seer had been worn down it wasn't
working properly hmm so when he pulled
the hammer back it just released right
away and slammed that's a gross
negligence by the production company if
that's what the case was the handing
Alec a a messed up gun is is negligence
no what what gets me is all the people
on Twitter who are who defended Alec
Baldwin when I was tweeting about it and
they're like clearly you don't know
anything about how movie sets work and
I'm like
um I do whenever you hand someone a gun
it is the responsibility of the person
holding the gun period no matter what at
all times don't care yeah that's brings
me back to my question if two 18 year
olds have a camera set up in their
living room and one pulls up a gun and
she points it and shoots it and then
there's a bullet in it does that kid go
to prison or guy yes 20 year olds of
course just because there's a movie
camera on doesn't matter he should have
checked the gun yep right
shut it down a lot of things
but here we are man I don't know what a
crazy story Ian came in here and he was
like there's a video of it and I was
like no because everybody was saying
they filmed it right they filmed what
happened
oh literally they're filming right well
they might have been between takes I
don't know if it was rolling you guys
gotta watch this video by the way
there's a real video no it's a CGI
um and there's music which is a little
manipulative you know makes it creepy
but just watching the flow of it it just
looks so blatant on Alex part you
Thoughtless and blatant I mean the video
they made shows Alec just sitting there
and then he grabs the gun and goes bang
and shoots her like Manchurian Candidate
yeah lifeless eyes
it's pretty uh accurate on that front
yeah but just shows sitting there it's
like a perfect rendition of his face
yeah perfectly calm looks like he's
plotting something yeah I think I think
the story is important because it shows
how people who are aligned with the
establishment can uh just basically get
away it shows how coveted restrictions
can mess up a movie site so you can't
have your armor on set with your with
your acting to a team apparently if
that's possible they have an A B and C
team which is completely
unethical for someone to put those
people in that position of danger where
the armor can't deliver the gun to the
actor yeah if that's the case there's a
lot of things that this is blown out of
proportion and that production company
is liable for her death for her that's
why everybody's getting sued but you
can't squeeze blood out of a turnip they
were already on a low budget production
so I don't know what they're gonna have
left anyway
no I keep thinking about Roblox you guys
yeah do you guys know what Roblox is
have you heard of it I've been hearing
about it and I'm like oh what is it
Minecraft okay turns out it's the third
largest video game company in the world
next to Nintendo after Nintendo and
they've basically a video game making
platform and what they do is they give
the software away for free to little
kids to make video games but what they
call them as experiences on Roblox
because if they call them games they
wouldn't be allowed to put Roblox on the
App Store so they have 200 million or 2
million or whatever experiences that
these kids have made and then other kids
can go buy the games and then the kids
that make the game get like 17 of the
money or something and so it's basically
this child sweatshops of digital game
creation they're having these kids build
the metaverse now they're starting them
off and it's a corporation the kids
don't have access to the Roblox code so
if they want to go make their own Roblox
they can't they're stuck learning how to
build within the ROBLOX Corporation
system so we have to either make this
software free or plan for a
an eternity of servitude until we can
shake these people out of it because
these kids are desperate for money right
now maybe that's it maybe we're not in a
simulation we're in the metaverse
that's it and physics is the code like
math is the code like the universe you
know people are like it's a simulation
that we're all in now we're just in
we're in Mark Zuckerberg yes because if
you go into the metaverse and you don't
have the code of the system it's like
it's like not knowing math
in this reality and them hiding that
from you
don't let it happen man all right let's
go to super chats thanks homie thanks
for that special Roblox shout out if you
haven't already subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
smash that like button and uh go to
timcast.com become a member help support
all the work we do um as a member you
are keeping Chris Carr employed so
that's a that's important I'm sure Chris
is extremely important yes I have small
children to feed thanks right and you
also get access to those member segments
we're gonna have one coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m but let's read these
super chats
all right let's see I can't read the
name of the first Super Chat because
YouTube blocks it but uh like the honk
button don't forget to do that they say
Tim when are you going to have another
guest on like vosh that speaks in
leftist platitudes to mask ignorance
seriously though please tell him he'd be
more effective speaking the common
vernacular oh
you know what really works for the left
and we saw this um
back during gamergate with a lot of
these personalities who were you know
prominent feminist academics jargon
works because it makes people think that
you're smarter than they are and that
you should follow them or listen to them
because they're smart so they say things
using really big words that make no
sense instead of simplify simplified
language to convey real ideas that's why
indoctrination on college campuses is so
effective it's like I think George
Carlin um has a good bit about it when
he was like shell shock you ever hear
his bit on shell shock and he's like you
know over time we keep making it more
more serious
post-traumatic stress disorder like it's
a longer and more like you know verbose
yeah because that's what people in left
are attracted to there you go
all right Raymond says wait Tim is not
far right I don't know Wikipedia says so
actually Wikipedia calls me a weirdo
Centrist yeah they're like yeah it says
like uh Vice says that I'm left and
right but it's funny because you know my
Wikipedia page is always locked and then
as soon as I unlock it it gets
vandalized like crazy with other random
garbage hey Wikipedia I invented a
Zeppelin
the let's go Brandon blimp that's right
and I don't see that going up on
Wikipedia they took that article down so
here's what you do the article I don't
know where it is it's the guardian
somewhere that claims I invented a
zeppelin is retroactively correct and I
demand it be put back in my Wikipedia
profile
so as it is spoken so shall it be done
indeed
all right Matt bruckett says Wheeling
School District in Illinois is Banning
parents who are against the mask mandate
same school district Charlie Kirk went
to and he's here this weekend please get
the word out oh Wheeling I'm familiar
with Wheeling I've skated up there once
or twice I think you know back in the uh
was that North North West suburbs
sh says after hearing that TD just froze
some accounts today I just closed all
four of my accounts with them Canadian
Bank Canada bank run good yeah if you've
uh look I'm not gonna give anybody
Financial advice but I'm gonna say if it
were me and I had accounts with TD Bank
and I heard they they froze people's
accounts for political reasons I would
pull my money out of that bank so fast
not for political reasons because
they're gonna freeze your money exactly
someday yeah yeah you don't know when
it's coming man and you're gonna wake up
one day and you're gonna try and go to
McDonald's to get your coffee and
they're gonna let your car's declined
sir and you're gonna be like oh no that
can't be right and they're gonna be like
you're gonna pull up your app and say
Frozen Frozen gonna be like whoa I need
gas what am I gonna do and they're gonna
be like sir we couldn't help but notice
that you were posting on social media
and in support of an Insurgent
insurrectionist movement so we've Frozen
all of your money
yeah sorry I'd rather I'd rather have a
big envelope full of cash under my
mattress and then put money in a TD Bank
account I changed my bank for much less
than that yeah sure did I did I was at a
at a Wells Fargo once yeah oh yeah years
and years ago and I can't remember what
happened it was something really like
Petty yeah I mean they like they made me
wait and then were kind of rude to me
when I was like politely waiting so then
I walked up and said you know I was
gonna make it make a deposit but I'm
changing my mind withdraw all of it and
there's a Bank of America literally
across the street 10 feet and I walked
in and I was like I'll go with you
instead I got a story I'd like for you
guys to hear I was with Bank of America
and I cashed a check that I got from
someone on Craigslist first red flag
don't ever do that don't ever take a
chance
1500 bucks or a thousand and they cashed
it and they gave it all me all the money
immediately so I spent it within like 10
minutes uh 800 of it of the thousand and
then like a day went by and actually the
check bounced we have to take the money
back so they put me at negative 800 in
my account and I was like yo I called
him up I'm a customer of the bank you
sold me me the money you can't take it
back and she was like I agree with you
sir but there's nothing we can I can do
wow no no never went back yeah I don't
think you understand Ian there's nothing
they can do huh if you give them a check
as on the level and they give you the
cash and then later on turns out they
shouldn't have given you the money
that's on them I that's what I'm saying
they can't take that back they already
cashed the check oh no no hold on Ian
they literally can't and they didn't did
they they gave me the money and then I
spent it and then they they took the
money back as and they gave me a
negative charge and then you stop using
the account then I to cancel my account
yeah yo Ian if I walk up to you and say
Ian and they put me on creditors had
coming after me and stuff if I come
after you and say you owe me a hundred
dollars
you could just say no but they had
creditors hit me for years they still
get stuff in the mail it's like it's
such after seven years it it yeah it's
no yeah but but they send letters to you
and if you respond to the letter then it
kicks it back on again and you gotta
wait another seven years they try and
trick you yeah they gotta they try and
trick you but I mean let me just ask why
were you cashing a check from Craigslist
I was living in LA and I was working
like I was working doing body work on
the beach like just living paycheck to
paycheck and I sold a bunch of my magic
cards for money and I did and the guy
was like I'll just give you 1500 for all
of them because he didn't want to go
through them one by one check and he
gave me a check but I did get 800 bucks
out of it
they're supposed to make sure the check
is clear before they give me the money
they should have done that yeah man or
just gave him the money and walked away
I don't know yeah valkyria says Ian
you're weird you're random but I'll
still give you a bear hug love you mate
and the rest of the gang two more days
till total Warhammer three blood for the
blood God all right do you play
Warhammer Ian I played a little bit of
Total War Warhammer
um
two and one
but I never really I played Warhammer
tabletop do you guys ever play that
Space Marines gray wolves no the Eldar I
think are my favorite they're these like
alien elves that have really high-tech
Weaponry Distortion cannons that can
make things vanish like from thin air
that was more Halo particularly sounds
good Space Marines let's read this we
got Raymond The Turk Longwell says bro
Michael is 40 today happy birthday
Michael when he sees this later drunk
he'll be happier than Luke is when he's
forcing signatures to work out
signatures yeah for the Vlog yeah he
made everyone sign a thing saying they'd
work out oh okay all right all right yep
well happy birthday Michael yeah happy
birthday happy birthday
let's grab some more Super chats
Let's see we got Ricky cases Ottawa
Police Chief resigns that's right that's
crazy man
all right it's me says they can turn the
protest on its head by just driving five
miles an hour now what the government
going to do and same effect
yeah exactly that's what I was saying
before if a bunch of truckers just drove
they could be like hey you're blocking
the road and they'll be like I'm not
trying to I'm driving but there's just
so many trucks here yeah imagine if you
had the freedom Convoy you know with how
many thousands of truckers instead of
actually just barricading of any Bridge
or anything they just drove it would
just be jammed up
and then you go in circles
what was that one CNN analyst she was
like her solution was like slashed their
tires
everyone on Twitter was like uh so
you're just gonna slash like hundreds of
tires it just kind of develops the
purpose yeah
yeah so people were commenting like if
you do that they'll burst literally
burst yeah you'll get yeah a lot of
pressure man don't do that yep
Michelle says Ultra dough has to do is
comply and the mandates and all the
truckers will go home it really
shouldn't be that difficult yeah
seriously think about being one of these
crackpot authoritarians supporting this
no you should comply and just take the
injection your body is meaningless
creepy man
all right what is this
Jeremy wyan says yes because farmers and
plumbers want to rule the world
certainly don't
Okami says I knew that guy Not only was
he a psychotic Lefty he was uh he was
also used he's also used his meager Fame
in the local Punk scene to keep keep on
young teenage girls I don't know who
they're referring to are they referring
to I guess it's the guy that tried to
assassinate the mayor of Canada right
right right right
yikes creepy
Ian Bridges says Tim the firearm seized
at the Alberta Montana border were
mostly from a local residence not from
Vehicles the media lies all the time oh
interesting wow
John boy says Jordan Peterson
interviewed one of the truckers he said
what they they what they want is an end
of the vax Mandate and passport Elaine
Maxwell convicted in Epstein case so
media coverage they are more interested
in Rogan
interesting
Michael says I'm a boomer and I'm
watching you yes there are many Boomers
who watch thank you but uh you know my
point was about Boomers aging out is not
meant to be disrespectful it's just that
you know boomers are aging and so
they're less likely to be in industry in
corporations and politics although for
some reason in politics they're sticking
around in in DC man
greasy Nails says is it always a charge
of misinformation without giving an
example also Fortenberry what is the
deal is he getting the
Hughes go for from the FBI what is that
I don't know
I don't know I don't know what that
means
he was cow I'm not sure don't know what
that is oh sorry
Lumberjack says this is what a
progressive woke leader does acting like
a dictator act uh keyword acting Drama
teacher Ian we need your mental energy
so say so say we all this is the way
hunk well there you go
okay thanks I'm gonna fix my posture so
the energy can flow there you go Carolyn
says Tim I'm a 60 year old six I'm 60
years old and a proud Boomer I'm a fan
can you please stop telling me I'm dying
every chance you get thank you
with all due respect aging Out means a
variety of things that doesn't mean
you're dying retiring yes yeah like
retiring and so when um gen Z and
Millennials are aging in you have a
millennial being appointed to the CEO of
a new company that Millennial energy is
coming in you know let me just say you
know the Boomers I could be wrong but
boomers are the ones who made the Next
Generation right it was Boomers right oh
yeah so yeah yep yep yep still living
with the consequences you did good and
then gen xers and Boomers joined forces
to make shows like Stargate
and uh what other good stuff was there
in the like Diana Jones oh or that
Firefly Firefly was pretty fireflies
good Stargate was great Stargate was so
great yeah that was Boomers in general
number four then Millennials came in and
they were just like but can we make it
so like this the heroes in a wheelchair
all right
okay way to go Hugo's not good enough
and the villain's not bad enough make it
more obvious but can we make the hero a
villain who steals clothing from a guy
on a motorcycle because he tells her to
smile
and is a girl actually isn't uh the guy
who made Ghostbusters 2016 he was a gen
xer wasn't he
Paul feige or whatever his name oh yeah
oh that guy yeah I didn't see his dad
probably Captain Marvel where she stole
the motorcyclist yeah that's Terminator
two they just ripped it off a turn there
too yeah yeah so he's like he's like you
should smile more and she's like and
then she steals his clothes derivative
but I guess the point was like she's
supposed to be a bad guy brainwashed or
whatever but it was just so obvious what
they were going for with Captain Marvel
where it's like there's a man who
suppressed her power by putting a device
on her and in the end she realizes she
has the power all along and like breaks
free or something and he keeps telling
her to control her emotions no for real
he's like you need to control your
emotions she's like ah it's like what
she has two it made no sense because
like we're talking about she can shoot
energy beams from her hands getting to
control that she needs to use that as a
weapon against bad guys and he's like
control your emotions don't use your
energy weapons or whatever he's right
but there's a better way to communicate
that with someone than tell them to stop
and then she's got this thing
suppressing it I don't understand why
they would give her all of these powers
and bring her on the team if they didn't
want her to use it it was basically just
like you know and then he's like no
man's Gonna Keep Me Down
you know yeah oh my gosh all right let's
read let's read Trey Allen says Ian
mentioning why do listen to these people
in uh wigs reminds me of Always Sunny
the gang cracks the Liberty Bell
I haven't seen that in a long time
all right
2D system says is it against YouTube TOS
to call for everyone to just not file
their taxes this year I think it is I
think it's illegal so yeah I like the
idea of organizing Mass Civil
Disobedience with internet video but you
got to be careful with with terms of
service and stuff too
I I would err on the side of like if
you're gonna do it do it on your own
network but you know once the video's up
they pull it down I don't know I think
everyone should be uh happy and proud to
to pay their taxes yeah
well that's that's the point
we should be but we're not we're not
happy you know there's a great meme
someone said is a lefty they were like I
would like Universal Health Care and
then they were like conservative
response well then who's going to pay
for it and they're like me you idiot
stop taking my money to blow up kids and
I'm like my other solution is like stop
taking my money to blow up kids let me
keep it and I'll buy Healthcare with
that too right I'm down for either left
or right populist response Thomas Massey
was saying we could repeal the
Department of Education or do whatever
to remove it 400 million a year then we
could split that to the states 8 million
per state for to for teachers there you
go interesting that might be a good
approach no I'm not a fan of that
of splitting up the doe I don't like
education Public public education
yeah give it to families yeah if you
give it to families I think we need uh I
think we'd be much much better off with
like a voucher system maybe yeah yeah
families so they can go wherever they
want yeah
you choose
how do you pronounce this Kyoshi says BC
Canuck here the Convoy Freedom protest
have been inspiring finally giving a
sliver of Hope after two long years
however every day I fail to shake off a
dread that grips me hard I'm worried
about where this All Leads that Nails it
that's exactly how I feel about this
situation the night is always darkest
before the dawn yeah fair enough
yep we got a couple people to Bob and
Ted mentioning defiant elves was
suspended on Twitter today I saw that
bummer
this is from John he says 28 caliber is
actually a thing it's equivalent to
seven millimeter so a seven millimeter
Remington Magnum is a 284 caliber bullet
kind of like the 556 is a 223 so
basically 28 caliber is a thing but no
one refers to it that way so look but
but sure but you're saying a 284. the
point is in the film The Dark Knight the
guy on the stand pulls a gun it doesn't
go it fails to fire misfires and then
Harvey Dent grabs it takes it apart and
he goes Chinese made 20 caliber if you
want to kill a public official I
recommend you buy American and they're
like they're all clapping and then I
remember when I first watched the movie
I was like yeah and then I watched it
again a few months ago and have it now
having purchased many guns and I was
like and I went 28. I was like I don't
have any of those what and I looked it
up and as soon as you Google it it's
like it's not a thing that's funny they
have no they they couldn't have even
asked somebody he could have said nine
millimeter you know or he could have
said like
something Chinese I don't know
making a reference to a gun made in
China
I don't know
I imagine I actually don't have any
chinese-made guns all my all of my guns
are American Turkish how dare you say
something like that what that I don't
have any Chinese man I have dare you say
something like that look where you are
[Laughter]
can't say stuff like that on YouTube
what's wrong with it oh yeah that's
right
all right Joshua Ryman says Tim I've
been watching since May 2020. you
brought hope and Solace where at the
time there was none of I am in Madison
Wisconsin conservative and a member of
timcast my family and I believe keep
pushing forward and God bless thank you
very much I really I really appreciate
it nice let's see Bookworm says Tim your
crypto bait and switch Theory you've
mentioned a few times is not new look up
nasara some people calling it The
quantum Financial reset and I think it's
benevolent others think it's planned and
reason for Q psyop yeah I've heard about
that stuff but that's that's not
necessarily the same thing I mean I get
it Bitcoin exists and people are doing
stuff with it and all of these big
financial institutions are adopting it
what are we hearing now there's rumors
uh maybe maybe this is this is actually
out there that's oil companies are gonna
get into the mining game do you hear
that interesting I tweeted out that I
thought maybe corporations shouldn't be
able to own crypto and I don't know why
I thought that it was really rudimentary
thought but that like if they're going
to take crypto which they could it would
just go straight through to the
employees hmm
it's very dangerous to like corporations
have like a personality when it comes to
finance
Kevin says I live in Anaheim hell yeah
Disney owns US town of mouse I was down
there when um
during the riots in Anaheim several like
almost 10 years ago now and it was crazy
the response they had police on
Horseback with boken wow okay that is is
that the two balls with the no that's a
bolus oh bolus look it up okay
I think it's I think it's called the
boken b-o-k-k-e-n is that what it is I
think so it's a spin or something it's a
wooden sword yeah oh my God it's a long
Japanese wooden sword used for training
in kenjutsu yeah and so they're riding
horseback with these really long wooden
swords you know like guiding people and
like swinging them around that's real I
love it blue sea says Tim some Gen X
parents had kids age 35 plus we watch
you and have gen Z teens so there is
hope that is that is good to hear yes
absolutely I mean you know we talk about
Generations but there is a wave it's a
gradient it's not like everyone is just
35 and 25 and although you know there
are some people who probably Envision a
world in which everything is deeply
controlled and people just you know
breed when told they're concerned about
population growth they don't want people
having too many children and things like
that
so then they can oh interesting Divine
owls was suspended for ban Evasion for
what band evasion oh interesting I call
BS yeah I don't believe that yep
sure enough pressure better calf care
says in the words of the great uh Rakata
under every judge's robe is just a naked
dude or woman I mean yes yeah
technically correct that's kind of
correct
Christopher says Tim my wife and I moved
to West Virginia this year the freedom
is amazing we want to raise chickens yes
what do you do with your males we don't
want to kill them only because they're
inconvenient love the show can't wait to
visit freedomastan so
um well
we have five roosters
in chicken City we've removed the Black
Star chickens and sent them off to
fredamistan which is their you know
their own little version now I hope
they're doing all right we have people
there taking care of them but as we're
building the new space
we only have two roosters here now and
it's Roberto and his son Roberto Jr and
they get along just fine it's they have
a they have a massive amount of space
there have been no problems so what I
was told by several people is that
because he was a baby and grew up around
all of them and the rooster they're
they're fine and they won't fight but uh
there may come a time when they're both
fully grown and then Roberto JR says I'm
in charge now but uh what I read is it's
a misconception that roosters kill each
other they only do if you take two
different roosters who don't know each
other and put them in a small confined
space but if they grow up together they
have a pecking order they should be fine
that being said you try to keep them
separated and try to make sure the
roosters have enough is there always an
alpha rooster
yeah yeah so when I I used to live next
to somebody who had like 50 chickens and
they just separate into flocks so they
can freely move about in the in the
field but like you know one group of
chickens with one rooster over here and
then one who's over here and then one
was over here and they kind of just did
their own thing you know they had their
own crew
it is really funny to see that we
introduced the the three babies
that uh the first ones we raised when we
introduced them back into chicken City
now that they've you know all become
part of the same flock it's funny to see
Roberto who's the dad be very protective
of them you know when I when I'm trying
to like clean things out or move
something and he's like yelling at me
here's the crazy thing Roberto Jr who is
like he grew up with these these two uh
hens
I was trying to herd them back inside I
was letting them go out and eat berries
and you know eat grass and then when I
was trying to wiggle a stick at him to
get him to go he runs up and Bows his
head and like Puffs his wings out like
he was gonna fight me and I'm like man
he's a man now right we raised him from
a little baby who hatched out of that
egg and we watched it now he's all tough
like hey you stay away from my girls is
Junior the one that was singing that was
had like the unique no okay no Mr singer
is one of the black stars he has a weird
a weird you know he didn't peep he had
like a whistle of the two Roberto
Roberto Jr there uh they have different
crows what are they called what's the
sound called that they made yeah I guess
it's very very unique I can tell hear
them both throughout the day they come
on a different time well the funny thing
is when uh Roberto Jr was first learning
how to Crow he kept falling he's trying
really hard yeah oh yeah but now he's
got the hang of it and he's doing all
right but it's different right
he's cute all right let's read some more
Super chats
let's see
Chrome leader says if you can prove he
had control of the recoil you can prove
guilt that's interesting um if he was
firing and anticipated a blank and it
like not pulled his hand back or
something if he was anticipating it and
pull the trigger and control yeah you
could make an argument that he knew it
was loaded
especially if his finger was off the
trigger I gotta tell you man
uh maybe I'm wrong about this but my
understanding is if I was holding a gun
and uh I'll put it this way
we've got uh I I've got a KSG 25 right
it's a it's a uh pump action shotgun
with uh two mag tubes it holds 25
shelves One in the Chamber and 20 and 12
in each and uh you can put in like
turkey turkey shot or something 12 gauge
and then buck shot on the other side or
all right you know I shouldn't even say
that if you take a shotgun and you put
you know birdshot then Buckshot and you
tell someone it's only got bird shot
they are going to be very very surprised
when The Buckshot goes off because it's
going to be very different
so granted shotguns are much more
powerful
I think it's funny when Joe Biden's like
get a shotgun I'm like yeah if you can't
handle a shot I don't know if people can
handle shotguns man they're not you know
that they're not as simple as people
make them out to be sure are these
semi-automatic the the KSG no it's not I
said pump action oh pump action or
semi-automatic shotgun's illegal
um I think if the in in Maryland if they
have a pistol grip and they're semi-auto
they're illegal if they're
semi-automatic semi-automatic with a
rifle grip they I think they're legal
and then if uh but you know you could
have a pistol grip and pump and it's
fine but uh the point is
Alec Baldwin
anticipating The Recoil I think is very
interesting
yeah because that that's that's
something moving that slug out and he
anticipated it
the fact that he said he didn't know she
had shot with a live bullet I'm calling
BSR no yeah no way it's got to be a lot
like we've got
um we've got a variety you know over in
West Virginia a variety of different
shotgun shell types
and when I'm talking to people and
training them I always like to give them
like snake shot like some like game load
something really weak
but you're not going to give someone a
slug on their first you know attempt at
firing a weapon yeah so you give them
something lighter
for him to be in control of it I just I
just say BS man I say BS
it's me says Baldwin is producer lots
lots to lose
yep
man
it's crazy stuff
let's read some more
Leslie Dow says he didn't react to her
death because because he's a sociopath
Ryan says Alec Baldwin said she was
intense
that's right is that how you describe
your friends no no absolutely not it's
it's like it's like a semi-negative
thing to call somebody you know what I
mean you're an intense person yeah it's
neutral well it's a neutral way of
criticizing that right like who wants to
be around someone who's intense all the
time stressful you know
Jesus I think Alec Baldwin playing Trump
for so long rubbed off on him Ruff
rubbed off on him I I can shoot a man in
the White House lawn and everyone will
still love me he believed his own uh
press in his mind there's something to
that you know Heath Ledger did the The
Joker and then took his life basically
shortly after that's and I'm acting when
you get into method acting and you you
act you really believe you are the
character while you're doing it to make
it real it does change your brain
chemistry it was like Jim Carrey was
that movie Man on the Moon yeah
Expedition says first assistant director
here armorer is a crew and should be the
one who gives weapon first A.D armor and
actor all inspect oven together every
take and every time gun is brought out
sloppy on protocols or intentional
that's what I'm saying how do you assume
that multiple people all made the
perfect mistake that allowed him to pull
out a gun and shoot a woman and then be
like I don't know because like monkeys
with typewriters yeah seriously
yup all right let's see what we got
someone said something uh
all right
Let's uh Don White says defiant owls
being banned from Twitter is
unbelievable that account was nothing
more than a mirror yeah yeah didn't like
the mirror
Heiser flip says will you ever uh will
you ever have David packman on do you
agree with anything he says uh David is
always welcome to come on yes and I
think David is wrong because I don't
think David does does journalism and I
don't mean that as a as a a a as I don't
mean that disrespectfully when Dave
Rubin told uh I think he tweeted AOC
like hey someone on your team thinks I'm
a journalist please stop sentence to me
she oh no no he was like please stop
sending me your press releases and then
she responded with oh someone must have
thought you were a journalist we'll get
you removed promptly all these leftists
were like oh sick burn and it's like
Dave Rubin was never a journalist he's a
comedian he's a comedian political
commentator yeah so he was like I'm not
a journalist don't send me these and
they were acting like it was a burn it
just makes no sense so anyway what I
mean is there have been uh um I've I
haven't watched as much of David's stuff
as in a while as I as I used to but you
know I mentioned often how when Ted Cruz
correctly cited Politico and the New
York Times pertaining to Ukraine
meddling in the 2016 election to help
Democrats
instead of actually Google searching the
stories to see if it was true David just
mocked Trump and I'm just like it's a
weird thing
because it takes you five seconds to do
this to look up the New York Times
article that says Ukrainian court rules
that you know individuals meddled in the
election to help Democrats you can just
look that up it takes you five seconds
it's the New York Times but David didn't
even do that so my opinion on David is
he's entitled to his opinions on certain
things we have we have different
politics but I think over the past
several years he's just uh his show is
based on
you know look he provides commentary on
the commentary of others like in that
circumstance he was watching Meet the
Press and then commenting on the
opinions of Meet the Press instead of
doing research and one other example and
it's been a long time so
I think I think it would be a great
conversation
he he we ran two videos in the same day
one said Donald Trump's approval rating
you know uh disapproval all-time high
and mine was Donald Trump's approval
rating all-time high how could that be
possible well David used a single poll I
used an aggregate poll in aggregate
Donald Trump's approval rating reached
its highest point in a single poll
Donald Trump's approval rating was as
low it's ever been that's the difference
I suppose and you know at least how I
view our content but of course then if
you're a leftist you look at David's
stuff and you're like see he's right
everybody hates Trump and then they see
my content and they're like he's lying
that's not true you know we've all seen
the poll and I'm like I'm talking about
the real clear politics average which
includes all of the polls and I look at
538
I like Civics a lot though too for its
timeline
all right everybody if you haven't
already smashed the hunk button honk the
like button right now and give us those
likes and go to timcast.com become a
member help support the show keep our
journalists employed and as a member
you'll get access to our exclusive
member segment segments we're going to
have one coming up for you around 11 or
so p.m tonight so make sure you check
that out you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
Drew you want to shout anything out yes
I have a big announcement I signed a
deal with Turning Point USA we will be
launching a show called front lines I'll
be hosting five days a week it'll be at
2 p.m Pacific Standard time every single
day and we will be covering the news
every single day but also we will be
deploying journalists we're setting up a
team as well and connecting with
journalists and on the ground reporters
worldwide because you know I think we
have seen this decline in journalism
we've seen this decline in reporting and
I think one of the most essential uh
centerpieces this is just my opinion I
know a lot of journalists May disagree
is actual on the ground reporting like
having people there because we could sit
here and comment on the news uh but I
think we get stuff wrong sometimes
because we're not actually there and
none of us are perfect but that's kind
of what we want to start bringing more
to the table with my show as well as
actually talking to the people on the
ground getting what's going on worldwide
not only the United States so that's
coming down uh the pike soon and my
first episode will be this upcoming
Tuesday and I promised all my followers
and my audience that I would eventually
do something with Kyle Rittenhouse so
just publicly Kyle will be my first
guest on episode one this Tuesday
breaking down what we both went through
during the trial and what he has coming
down which he has some pretty big
announcements coming next week you'll
hear it on my show only so I'm excited
for that thank you guys you guys can
follow me on Twitter Drew H live you can
follow me on my YouTube channel I think
that's in the description I think so
thank you guys for having me it's gonna
be awesome all right I just want to
shout out our amazing journalists on on
the team we got uh the head writer
Hannah Claire the tireless Michael we've
got Jay Lee we've got Charlie we've got
the Fearless a lot and of course we have
our esteemed editor-in-chief the
Unstoppable into fatigable force of
nature that is Cassandra McDonald
lover yeah formerly Cassandra Fairbanks
of course yeah she sent me um some video
over monkeys all you got to do is ask
nice Drew just to clarify when people go
to watch your show on Tuesday what is
the URL that they hit yes they can watch
it on the Turning Point USA YouTube
channel it'll be on Facebook it'll be
Twitter I think they're going to get it
on getter eventually and then the
website as well it's live cool man it'll
be live every single day you guys can
follow me Ian crossland.net if you want
to get in touch with me via social
networks and I will look forward to
talking to you see you later yeah
awesome yeah Drew is that that comes in
podcast form right eventually I think
they're going to run it with the podcast
but right now we're just launching the
live show and I'm just super stoked
because it's gonna be awesome to see how
this it's like my madness coming into
their world and I think people are
really going to start to see how that
unfolds because one of the main things I
wanted to get across was like I'm going
to be me I'm going to stay me I'm not
going to change me I'm just going to
continue doing what I'm doing on a
bigger platform and that's the goal yeah
absolutely I love that all my like on
the ground reporters are really coming
if you follow me on Twitter and my
Sour Patch Lids we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
make sure to sign up support our work
and we'll see you all there bye guys